This is Jocko podcast number
31 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Vornado Simpson watched three
men concluding Hutto and
Hudson go into a hut with
a girl aged about 17 her
trousers were forcibly removed.
The girls held down
while she was violated.
Simpson observed this from the door.
Fagan was also part of the girls
or deal when they were finished.
The helpless captive were shot dead.
Her face completely blown away.
Torres stabbed several people with a
Bowie knife and was seen by Hutto raping a
girl. She was crying,
fighting, and resisting him.
Another soldier held her down
for Simpson. The crucial moment was
when he shot the woman and baby.
Soon after entering the village,
I went to turn her over and there was
a little baby with her that I had also
killed.
The baby's face was half gone.
My mind just went.
The training came to me and I just
started killing old men, women,
children, water buffaloes, everything.
Yeah,
we were told to leave nothing standing.
We did what we were told regardless
of whether they were civilians,
they was the enemy. Period. Kill.
If you don't follow a direct order,
you can be shot yourself.
Now what am I supposed to do?
You're damned if you do and
you're damned if you don't.
You didn't have to look for people
to kill. They were just there.
Okay,
I cut their throats, cut off their hands,
caught out their tongue, their hair,
scalp them.
I did it.
A lot of people were doing
it and I just followed.
I just lost all sense of direction.
I just started killing any kind
of way I can kill. It just came.
I didn't know I had it in me after I
killed the child. My whole mind just went.
It just went and after you start,
it's very easy to keep on.
The hardest is to kill the first time,
but once you kill,
then it becomes easier to kill the next
person and the next one and the next one
because I had no feelings,
no emotion, nothing.
I just killed.
I wasn't the only one that did it.
A lot of people in the company did it.
Hung them up all types of ways.
Any type of way that
you could kill someone.
That's what they did that day and me lie,
I was personally responsible
for killing about 25 personally.
I don't think beforehand anyone
thought we would kill so many people.
I mean we're talking
about four to 500 people.
We almost wiped out the whole village,
our whole community.
I can't forget the magnitude of the number
of people that we killed and how they
were killed.
Killed in lots of ways.
Do you realize what it's like killing
500 people in a matter of four or five
hours. It's just like the gas
chambers. What Hitler did.
You line up 50 people, women, old
men, children and just mow them down
and that's the way it was from
25 to 50 to 100 just killed.
We rounded him up to
meet a couple of guys,
just put the m 16 on automatic
and just mowed them down.
Good evening, Echo. Good evening.
Well,
that was an excerpt from a book called
four hours and me lie by Michael Bilton
and Kevin Sim,
and when I was prepping for this,
I mentioned to a couple people that I
was going to do me lie on the podcast
next.
And surprisingly,
a lot of people didn't
know what it was and,
and I thought everybody knew about me.
Lie To me, lie is a war crime.
It's an atrocity.
And what makes it so hard to talk about
is that it was an atrocity and a war
crime that was committed
by American soldiers.
Now,
of course there's people out there that
like to claim that you know that America
is this evil imperialistic empire,
which I am killing you.
It is not,
not by any stretch.
America isn't any incredibly benevolent
nation with a conscience and a saw that
as a whole
is good in have we done some things
in the past that don't reflect that we
absolutely have, but for the most
part, we have stood up for the week.
We have liberated the oppressed.
We defeated the Nazis,
we defeated the Imperial Japanese army.
We give aid and military assistance and
education in money to less fortunate
people all over the world all the time.
We are a good nation filled with,
for the most part,
good people,
but not all good people
and people
inside of people inside of humans.
There can be something very dark
in some times that darkness can
override the light
in.
That is exactly what happened in a small
village in Vietnam called me lie on
March 16th,
1968 zero seven 15 in the morning,
a massacre
in atrocity,
the murder of hundreds
and hundreds of old men,
women and children on armed,
begging for mercy,
shot,
stabbed, blown up, raped,
tortured, killed, murdered,
and no,
I don't like talking about this is
specially when it's Americans that are
committing the sin.
When we talk about the Nazis in Germany
and we've talk about the Chechens and
garage need,
we talk about the Japanese Shinto in the,
in the Malaysian jungle
on the Hutus in Rwanda.
I don't like that,
but this is us.
Okay,
still the question comes,
it came into my mind.
Do I do this?
Do I talk about this?
Can I talk about this in the
bottom line is not can I,
but we have to. We have to cover
this. We have to talk about it.
We can't ignore it. We can't deny
it. We have to take ownership of it
to admit it,
to air it out and to keep it in the
front of our minds to ensure that we do
everything we can
to make sure nothing like
this ever happens again.
War is hell
and me lie is the ninth circle of hell,
the part,
and let's go there to
make sure we remember
and start by looking at
the path that led there
and in order to look at the path that
led there or we're going to start just by
a little bit of broad strategy because
there's plenty of blame to go around.
And when you look at the broad
strategy in the way it was laid out,
here's a little piece on general
Westmoreland who was running,
running the strategy in Vietnam.
General Westmoreland strategy of attrition
also had an important effect on our
behavior.
Our mission was not to win.
Terrain receives positions,
positions, but simply to kill.
To kill Communist and kill
as many of them as possible.
Stack them up like cordwood
victory was a high body count.
Defeat a low kill ratio
wore a matter of arithmetic.
The pressure on unit commanders to produce
as many corpses was intense and they
in turn communicated it to their troops.
It's not surprising,
therefore that some men acquired a
contempt for human life and a predilection
for taking it.
Okay,
so that that's, that's the, that's
the environment that you're in,
the environment you're in,
that's being encouraged to kill,
kill as many as possible.
That's coming from the top.
That's the broad strategy not
to win this hill. It's kill
and who you talking to and who's
receiving this. Here's a little,
a little piece on Charlie Company,
which is the army unit that this is
based on and that that committed this
atrocity.
We were kids 1819 years old.
I was 21 years old at the time.
I was one of the oldest people
around there among the common grunts.
Most of them had never
been away from home before.
They went into service and
they ended up in Vietnam.
Many of them because they thought they
were going to do something courageous on
behalf of their country.
So young kids and, and
nowadays, if you're young kid,
you're 1314 1618 you know,
guess what?
You might not have
traveled around the world,
but you've seen the world because you
have television, you have the Internet,
you can see all these parts of the world.
You can see all different
cultures and people. Well,
when you're from Iowa in 1967 you,
you,
you, you don't know anything about this.
So you're getting, next thing you know,
six months later you're in Vietnam
and here's a little bit of where you're
going to get your attitude from back to
the book to the troops of Charlie company.
Two American troops in general,
all Vietnamese were goofs,
dinks, dopes and slopes.
Soldiers who could not find the Vietnamese
who were their enemy soon struck out.
Why aren't we at the Vietnamese who
were supposed to be their friends?
How can you tell the enemy?
Varnado Simpson said they all look the
same to which another meal I veteran
added in the end.
Everyone in that country was the enemy.
In all wars. It is common for the enemy
to be dehumanized. But in Vietnam,
American soldiers also
dehumanize their allies.
Charlie company had not been in Vietnam
long before the pattern of brutality
leading to me.
Lie began their own losses and
injuries hastened the process.
Hatred, fear, racism and
revenge turned to beatings,
torture, rape, murder.
All of these offenses were committed
with impunity by individuals and groups
from Charlie company. And the weeks
before the massacre finally at me,
Eli, they discovered that having
dehumanize the Vietnamese,
they had also dehumanized themselves.
Okay,
so you're going to see this escalation.
And it's just like we
talked about with the,
with the Russian soldiers in Chechnya
and how it starts when they don't shave.
Yeah. And then they don't clean their
weapon and they don't stand watch.
And then the next thing you know,
they're not doing their duty
and they're being overrun.
You're going to see a similar escalation
here all around lack of discipline.
But it's in a way that they treat
the local populous. And you know,
I had one of my high
school teachers was a,
was a Vietnam veteran and when
I was going to high school,
the movie platoon came out
and,
and you can tell, actually you can
tell that the movie platoon, the La,
the book we did platoon
leader by Jim Mcdonough,
there's so many scenes in that book that
you can tell all of the north read that
book and put some of
those scenes in the movie.
There's no doubt about it because
even a character named Barnes in the,
in the book and in the movie
well platoon also showed,
you know,
a very high,
it portrayed the Americans in a very
rough light in many of the situations.
And when I talked to my, one of my
teachers in high school that wasn't,
was a Vietnam vet. And
he just said, you know,
the thing that they didn't show very
well because they show the guys coming in
and in really beaten people,
killing people,
burning villages. And what he
said was, you know, Jocko wheat,
we would walk around the village and
one of our guys would hit a booby trap.
Every day,
every other day,
and the villagers are out there
walking on the same trails,
but they're not getting blown up.
And after
weeks and then months of this
happening of me losing two guys,
three guys, six guys getting blown
up, getting killed, losing their legs,
losing their arms, losing their
lives, and the Vietnamese villagers,
they're not hitting anything.
Eventually in in our minds,
they become guilty.
Hmm.
Now,
when you have leadership that can
explain and restrain and control,
you can keep that stuff controlled,
but when you have leadership
that buys into that attitude,
you end up in a very bad situation,
which is where we're heading here in Ely.
Hmm.
Now,
back to the strategy.
The aim of American strategy was simple
to kill Vietcong in such large numbers
that they would not be replaced
or could not be replaced,
but how was this to be achieved without
at the same time killing large numbers
of civilians?
This was a problem to which no one on
the American side ever discovered a
satisfactory answer.
It was the biggest failure of the war.
It was a failure magnified enormously
by American strategic thinking.
For Westmoreland. Vietnam was a
war of attrition, a meat grinder,
as they called it in the Pentagon.
The object he explained was to bleed
the north to waken in the communist mind
the notion that they were draining their
population to the point of national
disaster for generations to
come to achieve this goal
and to win a war in a war
of attrition,
Americans had to kill Vietcong fighters
faster than the communists could replace
them as befits a great industrial power.
The war was to be fought
on an industrial scale,
Westmoreland like patent before him
intended to construct a killing machine.
So for noble as to be irresistible,
it's sheer size and power would pay
rise the enemy in this submission.
So there you go.
Once again,
it's very clear what the goal
is from a strategic level.
Kill as many as you can.
Yeah,
and this, this kind of spells out
how determined they were to do that.
Back to the book from the beginning
of American involvement involvement.
It'd become common practice for patrols
to call for artillery or narrow strike
if they received even
sniper fire from a village,
irrespective of whether
civilians also sheltered there.
By the end of 1966 fighter bombers were
making up to 400 such stories a day
added to be 52 raids in the country.
This meant that around 825 tons of bombs
were delivered every day a figure that
doubled by the tonnage of high explosive
fired by fired off by artillery.
The solution in Vietnam,
general debris told the visiting
emissary from the Pentagon is more bombs,
more shells, more napalm till the
other side cracks and gives up,
and that's what they got in 1967 and
article in life magazine claim that the
cost of killing a single
Vietcong guerrilla was $400,000
which included the cost
of 75 bombs in 150 artillery shells.
No nation in history had waged a war
with such little regard to expense.
Only days before me, Eli, Robert Mcnamara,
this retiring secretary of defense would
remind an audience gathered to record
his farewell from the Pentagon. That
more bombs had been dropped on Vietnam.
Then on the whole of Europe
during the whole of World War Two
so that's just, that's crazy. Especially
for me from my perspective, having,
having been in the war in Iraq and having
known guys that fought in Afghanistan,
the this idea that they take sniper
fire from a village and in calling air
strikes on the village is just something
that would not happen. Then you're,
that's why when people,
when people frame America as being this,
this power that just goes and crushes
and kills all these civilians,
I know for a fact it's not true. Yes,
obviously it happened in Vietnam,
but we go through great
lengths almost sometimes.
I'm telling you almost sometimes absurd
lengths to protect the civilian populace
in Iraq and Afghanistan. I could bring,
I could bring so many people on here,
on this program, just, just
seals. But I could bring any,
anybody from all kinds of diff,
every branch of the military to come
here and say, Oh yeah, here's what we,
here's the situation.
My guys were pinned down under fire.
We tried to get bombs dropped on
this building. No one would do it.
We couldn't do it. We weren't allowed
to do it. Yeah. And, and that's,
that's the reality today.
And you know,
part of that is we've matured as a nation.
Obviously we see there that that's
a problem. I mean, I'm not incur.
This is the way we should fight.
You know,
sometimes we go too far in one direction.
This was obviously too far
in the other direction.
[inaudible]
in, in Iraq. I remember you
mentioned something about the,
the, um, the enemy in Iraq
would use the civilian populace.
Oh, there's no doubt about
it. For like shields.
And they literally used
used kids as shields.
They knew our rules of engagement.
They knew that if they stayed in buildings
that were close to a mosque or work
close to a hospital,
that we wouldn't bomb it,
that we wouldn't hit it with with armor.
So they were very smart about how they
took advantage of our rules of engagement
and then we had to adjust our tactics.
So there there's no doubt the enemy
figures out what your rules of engagement
are and then they start to press you in
the seams of that rules of engagement is
try and take advantage of it
to the best of their ability.
Do you think that that that's
kind of an indicator that they
cared about their civilians less
than you cared about their activity,
that that is 100% accurate?
Of course. I mean the,
the Al Qaeda and surgeons
and now the Isis in Iraq,
they don't care about civilian
casualties at all. They don't care.
They literally don't care their own
their own. Well, that's crazy. Yeah.
In the civilians, okay. This is something
that never gets portrayed correctly.
The civilians don't want isis in charge.
The civilians didn't want outside in
charge. They knew what that would lead to.
And yeah, al Qaeda would use
their children as shields.
I mean I literally had snipers of mine
that shot al Qaeda guys carrying machine
guns in one hand and a
baby and the other hand.
And luckily we had really
good snipers. Yeah. So
back to the book here, we get to
talk a little bit about the company.
The company that this is about Charlie
company and a company is the company
soldiers generally around 150
people and you'll have three.
Generally you'll have
three platoons in there.
So your platoons are going to be 40,
50, maybe 60 people. Sometimes it's,
it's actually a lot more
flexible than people realize.
Sometimes in already army company we'll
have five platoons but generally three
platoons. What they'll have. So you know,
we're talking here probably about 150
guys in Charlie Company and they're guys
they lay out that kind of go into a
quick background of the different guys.
And really what it ends up showing you
is a, is a cross section of America.
Uh, some, some highlights, you know,
they got a guy named Fred Fred
Whitmere from just north of Pittsburgh.
You got a guy named Kenneth Hodges
from Dublin, Georgia. Um, uh,
farmer's boy.
You got a guy from Portland,
Oregon named Greg Olsen,
who's, who's a Mormon,
a devout Mormon and,
and you know from a good family,
you got another guy named Harry Stanley
from Gulf Port Mississippi who was
brought up by his mom who believed in
hard work school and Church on Sundays.
So you're looking at a
fairly normal cross section.
Michael Bernhardt came from a middle
class Catholic family from Long Island,
so he got just the,
the troops are just a cross
section and then you get to
one of the leaders in Charlie company
in charge of second platoon and his name
was William laws,
Cali lieutenant Calley
and he's going to end up
being are the monster year.
So back to the book,
who was Kelly in the early seventies a
small industry grew up trying to find the
answer toilers at this
looked for a monster,
but all they found was a nonentity,
a blend young man burdened.
It seemed with as much ordinariness as
any single individual could bear and
almost too much of a conventional and
commonplace to retain what is necessary
for human identity.
To press [inaudible] to the press,
Kelly was just about as
average in American as ever
came out of the nondescript
middleclass streets of Miami.
He could be any young American.
He was the quiet American.
It was noted with astonishment that he
emerged from a background which most
would regard as coming close to
the American ideal. Elsewhere,
it was said that his life could have
been lifted from the cover drawing of the
old Saturday evening post is averageness
had made him so invisible at one
college he attended that all anyone
could remember about him was that he paid
his rent regularly.
The many who combed through his
life found no shred of deviance,
nor even a single distinctive feature
other than his height. Five, four,
five feet, four inches. He'd
come from a stable family.
He'd been neither particularly
popular or unpopular.
He had no particular talents
and few, if any, enthusiasms,
water skiing was the closest he ever
got to violence throughout a long
education.
He'd shown no aptitude for learning.
His college career simply fizzled out
and that's one of the things,
I mean you can see this guy
just is a white your blank
White Brett of just plain,
just plain and that's
what they find about them
now of a company itself.
They say back to the book
Charlie company was very average,
so so Charlie company actually reflects
Cali and the fact that Charlie company
as a whole is pretty normal for a
company of army soldiers in Vietnam and
investigation ordered by the army chief
of staff in 1970 re revealed that 87% of
Charlie company's ncrs or
high school graduates nearly
20% above the army's norm.
Most of the men in Charlie Company
were between 18 and 22 years old.
Nearly half the company was black.
The piers report concluded that there
was little to distinguish Charlie company
from other rifle companies.
The men were generally representative
of the typical cross section of American
youth assigned to most combat
units throughout the army.
They brought with them the diverse traits,
prejudices and attitudes,
typical of the various regions of the
country and segments of society from
whence they came.
Okay.
Normal people.
And why it's important to remember that
as we dive into this and as this story
develops,
you're going to see these normal
people do completely demonic things.
And now we talk a little bit here
about there in Hawaii and they're going
through some training to
prepare them for Vietnam.
Back to the book,
what most Charlie Company
veterans remember about the
training was its unreality
and how little it prepared them for
what they had to face in Vietnam.
For Fred Woodmere, it seemed they had
been preparing for World War II or Korea.
Calli thought they could go to Vietnam
and be Audie Murphy's kicking the door,
running the hooch,
give it a good burst kill.
Bernado Simpson said you can't
have no type of training.
Can compare with what war's like none.
There's no such thing as preparedness
for war. We trained and we should,
we're so psyched up and they program
you to kill and to go to Vietnam,
you know? But once you get there,
it's a different situation.
Now.
I spent my last three years in the
military training guys for Warren. I have,
I'll tell you right now,
we train guys really well for war and the
training that I received preparing for
war did a great job and we improved upon
that. The more combat experience we got,
the better we got at training
and preparing guys for war.
But you can see how you could you,
you know how important the training is
and the training has got to be realistic
to the situations you're going
to be put in. And clearly,
you know they them saying that this
was like World War II or Korea.
Well in World War II,
Korea,
there's vast differences between
what you're dealing with Vietnam.
I mean World War II or Korea,
you're fighting against the enemy.
Uniformed troops that are on the other
side of a line that are attacking you,
right?
That's what,
that's what world war two and Korea
was very much like for the most part,
another person in a different uniform
that you aren't going to fight and kill
and here we just have
something totally different.
People that are mixed in with
the villages, there's no fee.
There's no front line anywhere.
They're dressing the same.
Sometimes they have a gun,
sometimes they don't. It's,
it's an infinitely challenging,
more, more challenging situation.
Now here we go back to the book.
According to Cali,
the only lesson every GI learned
was not to trust anybody.
It was drummed into us.
Be Sharp on guard.
As soon as you think these people
won't kill you, zap in combat,
you haven't friends,
you have enemies.
Over and over again at ocs we
heard this and I told myself,
I'll act as if I'm never secure as if
everyone in Vietnam would do me in as if
everyone is bad.
Yeah.
Michael Bernhardt was also concerned.
Charlie company did not match up to
the high standards that have order and
discipline. He had learned at
the Lasalle military academy.
So this is one of the
soldiers. He had gone to a, uh,
a military type high school where they
had good discipline and they learned
about the military. And then when he
got in he went to airborne school.
So he was more the higher
end soldier back to the book,
trained as a parachute,
as he was disappointed to have been
transferred to a run of the mill infantry
company.
Bernhardt was unusual for an enlisted man.
He was a military animal,
a stickler for authority,
and was happiest when things
were being done by the book.
But it was not this system
that bar bothered Bernhardt.
He believed that good soldiers
not only needed discipline,
but liked it. It was the lax
discipline in Charlie company.
And the fact that officers did not always
insist on their orders being carried
are out that worried him
in an argument with Kelly.
Shortly after arriving in Hawaii,
he found the young lieutenant callow
and lacking in leadership qualities.
So right now we're already seeing some,
some chinks in the armor
of lieutenant Calley.
And if you remember what
Hackworth said about, about me,
Eli,
he talked about Kelly and
he said that Kelly had been
uh,
kicked out or failed.
He'd failed officer candidate school
three times and they just wanted to, hey,
we need more guys. We need to have
better numbers getting through.
Go ahead and pass the guy. So you've got
a guy that lacks leadership and it is,
I mean it's interesting the talk
about how bland this guy is.
I mean somebody that's that bland
that they literally have nothing,
no characteristics.
Obviously the guy lacked some leadership
characteristics as well because he has
no characteristics and now you've got
the young soldiers looking at the guy and
thinking he doesn't have,
he doesn't have any leadership.
And this is a, this is a part that
I highlighted because I think it's,
it's an interesting perspective of
what it was like to go to Vietnam.
Back to the book, we flew over on
a Kent Continental Airlines plane,
Fred Whitmere recalls.
It was a weird situation,
a civilian plane with a
civilian stewardess and crew.
They were flying both ways.
They were flying people out as well as in,
so they got to see both ends.
I remember getting off the plane and
the stewardess just stood there crying.
As we unloaded,
they were more attuned to what we
were getting into than we were.
That's pretty surreal.
Now
they start talking about what it's like
there and what they're doing and there's
a, there's a province, they're that they,
they're to concentrate on
a province in Vietnam and some of the
problems that they have there in a
province deemed correctly to be
overwhelmingly sympathetic to Vietcong.
This meant eliminating the countryside.
The villages were bombed,
burned down and pull verist.
Sometimes villagers would be warned in
advance that their homes were about to be
wiped off the face of the earth,
sometimes not.
It was common practice to shell or bomb
any village from which the US soldiers
had taken any fire, even small
arms without any warning at all.
The destruction was on an almost
unimaginable scale. So again,
is this something that in the wars that I
fought in, that we would, this is on we,
we would never do that.
It wasn't just like, oh,
we took rifle fire from a village bomb.
The whole thing that was not happening.
This was the reality behind Westmoreland's
prediction in 1965 that the war will
bring about a moment of
decision for the peasant farmer.
He will have to choose if he stays alive.
American officials frequently referred
to this choice. The choice is yours.
One leaflet dropped on
villages proclaimed.
If you refuse to let Vietcong use your
villages and hamlets as their battlefield,
your homes and lives will be spared.
1 million leaflets,
leaflets a day were being dropped on
quieting province [inaudible] province at
this time.
The whole exercise assumed that the
largely illiterate peasants could actually
read them from 1965 to 1970 to 50 billion
leaflets were dropped over Vietnam,
1500 each for every
member of the population.
So
that's just w when you think about we're
dropping these leaflets to tell the
people what to do and,
and most of the popular,
a lot of the population is illiterate.
Hey, get out of your village. Well,
there's a piece of paper flying from
the sky and I don't know what it says.
Yeah.
Back to the book to stay and be killed
or to go join thousands of other refugees
in the squalor of refugee camps or the
mushrooming shanty towns around the towns
and cities.
What kind of a choice was this?
But for the Americans,
the whole point of clearing an area of
countryside of its people was so that
anyone who remained must be Viet Cong.
These areas became free fire zones.
Anything that happened to someone who
chose to remain in or return to a free
fire zone was their own fault.
They could expect the worst.
The belief that people had been given a
chance to get out, had made their choice,
made the strategy morally
workable in a free fire zone.
The pursuit of a high body count could
proceed unencumbered by the need to
discriminate between combatants
and civilians at all.
Nowhere was this Brit breathtaking
carelessness of human life greater than in
night.
No one was actually saying kill civilians,
but no one's strive to keep them alive
because the killing of civilians came to
be seen as unavoidable.
Less and less time was spent on seeing
how it could be avoided to American
spokesman,
the death or injury of noncombatants
who was always accidental and inevitable
tragedy of war and therefore
somehow uncorrectable
me. What do you eat? You do. It doesn't
take a genius to figure this out.
When did the Americans are bombing
your village and they're killing your,
your son, your husband, your
wife, whatever. I mean at what,
whose side are you going to be
on? You know, it's, and we know,
we know that the VC were brutal.
We'll look at the end of platoon commander
when the VC come in and murder the
half the village or three quarters the
village and burned down their huts and
blow up all their, all their
hooches. We know that the VC,
you were capable and and evil,
but when our strategy is,
hey, give him a quick warning, drop some
leaflets, tell them if they stay there,
they're VC. And if not, hey, we gave him
a chance. So if they're standing there,
there must be VC.
Hmm.
Charlie company's spent December guarding
bridges and practicing in the deserted
village of Duke foe.
The army called it in country orientation
and Australian advisor was brought
into instruct the company on
how to distinguish between
noncombatants, Viet Cong,
regular suspects and sympathizers.
He said it was very difficult.
So did other instructors from
the South Vietnamese army,
they got the same story
from former Viet Cong.
The Australian emphasize that you
should be extremely leery of children.
Medina testified later in
Medina is the company commander.
So the company has three platoons in it,
the overall in charge of the company's
guy named Medina. Now think about this,
not only, you're just
distinguishing between good and
bad. You got noncombatants,
which are, you know, friendly
civilians, Vietcong, regulars,
suspects and sympathizers.
And now you've got the Vietnamese
soldiers who are from Vietnam.
Obviously they're saying how hard
it is to distinguish who's who.
And then the Viet Cong,
the captured Viet cong themselves are
saying that it's very difficult to know
who's who.
So how is a kid from Iowa going
to be able to tell the difference?
We will expose to something
that went far beyond the world.
As we knew it said Fred Whitmere. We
had just left Hawaii with all its hotels
and nightclubs and bars and we wound up
in Vietnam where people went right out
and shit and the rice patty in the
morning drop their drawers right along the
trail at any time.
It was hard to consider people in the
modern day and age living like they did.
I think it would against our
value of what human life is.
Kelly was always frustrated
in his attempts to keep
the children away from his
men when they were guarding
bridges at duck foe,
all the men love them, gave the
kits, candies, cookies, chewing gum,
everything he said later,
not me, I hated them.
I was afraid of the Vietnamese kids.
So you know,
you've got the Australian guy saying,
hey, look, be leery of the kids.
You got the kid from Iowa, the normal
American grunt. He loves the kids,
he's good and he's giving them gum. He's
giving them food, playing with them.
It's all good. Meanwhile, Cali, again,
you start seeing the indicators
of what's about to take place.
You got a guy that's saying I hated them,
I hated them.
It's hard to develop hatred for
it. For a kid, for a five year old.
Nope.
Now they,
they become part of a,
a unit that's called Task Force Barker,
which is a multiple companies
of which Charlie companies,
one of them. And, and this lieutenant
colonel, look, battalion commander,
he is the, he is the commander of
this task force and they actually,
his name is Colonel Frank Barker.
So they named the task force after
him and they send them up to this,
to this province.
Now inside there,
back to the book,
inside their fire bases,
men of 10 men of the task force enjoyed
as much of the American world as could
be flown in by helicopter. They received
their mail, American newspapers,
Cold Beers, steaks, ice cream,
Coca Cola and playboy magazine.
But all around them was
the world of the Viet Cong.
And I got another, uh, another
interesting thing from this book just to,
just to show the extent that
they, that they did this, there's,
there was 40 ice cream plants built in
Vietnam to supply the troops with ice
cream, the and, and each Bu. Another
figure that I read was that each,
each person in each
soldier in Vietnam used uh,
a hundred pounds of supplies at day.
Crazy.
Okay.
Now the guys,
they move into this new projects,
province Quain NY and they
start to encounter some combat
and I'm very careful to say
they're not encountering,
they're not really encountering VC,
they're not getting an a
bunch of firefights but
they are getting in some and
this is there,
they're in their first fire fight in here.
We go back to the book of the
men in their first firefight.
We're discovering things about
each other and about themselves.
Greg Olson recalled we were pinned
down in a trench taking a lot of fire.
Sergeant Cowan was on one side,
one side of me putting up his helmet
to get some bullet holes in it.
Almost like it was a
music on the other side.
There was this other guy just
sobbing. He'd come on, glued,
crawling around like a dog.
Just lost it.
The first platoon withdrew under cover
of massive artillery bombardment.
According to some of the men,
Kelly was totally lost.
He led them back towards the river.
As they broke cover,
the snipers started up again.
Ron Weber Kelly's radio
operator took a shot,
which shattered his radio
set and tore his kidney out.
He died a few moments later.
Charlie company's first killed in action.
His horrified companions lifted him
onto the Hovering Med evac helicopter,
a Gi and shock blubbered and how old,
no one had known much about shock before.
If we got hit much harder,
we would all go into shock.
Cali told his count,
his court martial nearly three
years later. It was terrifying,
a terrifying experience.
In later years,
Kelly admitted that he'd been careless.
He led his men into an exposed position,
so they're in a firefight and they're
trying to break contact and Cali leads a
mountain to an open area and
gets one of his guys killed.
And then he asked to report back.
He got in a firefight. Okay, look,
how'd it go? Let's report back.
What's the body count? Cause that,
remember this is all about killing
is all about killing. Yeah,
and so he passes up the body count and
here's how he comes up with his body
count.
Ask later how he arrived at a body count.
Kelly had replied, you just make an
estimate off the top of your head.
There is no way to really figure out
exact body count. As long as it was high,
that's all they wanted.
I generally knew that if I lost a troop,
I better come back with a body count of
10 say I shot at least 10 of the enemy,
which was pretty hard when
you're only fighting one sniper,
so you've got these guys out in
the field and they're reporting,
they're just making up the body count.
Now think about what,
how the what the effect is house
on the war effort because General
Westmoreland's up there saying,
hey,
we're going to kill them until
they can't take it anymore.
Well guess how many people they killed,
right there is zero.
They didn't kill that sniper
and yet they're reporting
that they killed 10 well,
you multiply that over the whole country
and every unit that's out there that's
making up these body count
numbers and guess what?
Eventually Westmoreland thinks we're
doing a good job and killing a lot of bad
guys,
but we're not killing nanny.
Yup.
Yeah. And that can jam you up when you
have that like you in a different type of
scenario where you're getting reports
on a certain level of progress and
therefore a lot of times the decision,
the next decisions to be made are based
on that oh 100% 80 any situation that
you're in,
if you've got your troopers and your
subordinate leadership with a mindset that
they would rather lie to you, then tell
you the truth about what's happening.
You're not,
you're never gonna be able to make good
decisions because you're making your
decisions based on lies.
Yup.
Yeah.
Back to the book, frustration and anger
ate away at the company's a spree decor.
The men stopped believing that
Charlie Kong, meaning the Vietcong,
was afraid of Charlie
company faith in Medina,
the company commander was still high,
although some Gis felt he
pushed the company to hard.
Cali was another matter.
Opinion on him was universally hostile
according to one GI and his platoon Kelly
was a glory hungry person.
The kind of person who would have
sacrificed all of us for his own personal
advancement.
John Smale,
our squad leader in third
platoon called him a nervous,
excitable type who yelled a lot.
I think it's important for you to know,
smelled talk told the army cid that Cali
was so disliked by members of the unit
that they put a bounty on his head.
None of the men had any respect
for him as a military leader.
Greg Olson thought he was incompetent.
I remember instances that we
were lost one time at night.
Everyone knew we were lost,
but Calli wouldn't admit it.
So there you go. You got a guy, we talk
about this all the time. It's like, oh,
what do you do if you make a mistake,
you own the mistake. If you need help,
you say, Hey, you know what? I'm not sure
we were on the map right now. Let me get,
let me get someone up here and
do a map study helped me out.
Let's figure out where we are, but
instead he just lies. He doesn't admit it,
he doesn't own it, and no one is
going to have respect for them.
Back to the book,
someone else thought Kelly acted like a
small guy who had been pushed around a
lot by bigger people
before he joined the army.
Now that he had a 40 he didn't know
how to use it and he didn't listen to
suggestions. We, I talk
about this all the time.
If you're in a leadership position,
you need to listen to your people
up and down the chain of command.
This is one of the main thing that he's
getting called out on it, doesn't it?
But when he's wrong and
doesn't listen to suggestions,
many commented that there was something
about him that rubbed people the wrong
way.
Medina,
the company commander gave his junior
lieutenant a tough time and ridiculed him
in front of his men.
The captain called him
lieutenant shithead regularly.
One Gi remembered that tended to minimize
your opinion of him are get recalled.
Others recalled that Kelly's attempt to
win flavor with Medina were frequently
rebuffed with a sarcastic
listen sweetheart.
So now we have another situation where
you have a subordinate leader that's not
doing a good job.
He's not being a good leader.
People don't respect him and what his,
what is his superior,
don't undermining them in front of
his troops instead of counseling.
And instead of helping them set up,
pulling them aside and say, hey,
it's okay to admit when you're wrong.
Hey,
you need to take
suggestions from your guys'.
Instead he's calling them a
shithead lieutenant shithead
undermining him all the
time. So now you got, you get put
in Cali need even worse position.
Hmm.
Now
they continue to patrol.
They're starting to take some casualties
and they start to go down the spiral.
Okay.
Back to the book. Charlie company's drift
toward brutality. Took very little time.
It began with beating up suspects in
villages and quickly became more serious.
Bernhardt state aloof from the process.
Fred Woodmere did not.
They had explained that Geneva Convention
to us during our training and in the
beginning we did what we thought was
right and just turn a prisoners over.
But it was kind of hard after you'd been
there a while and you started seeing
learning, finding out what
real experience is all about.
Here you are fighting an enemy who
doesn't follow the Geneva Convention,
but you have to abide by it. It's like
being at a football team where you don't,
where you have to follow the rules to
the letter and the other team can do
whatever the hell they like.
The voices of authority in the company,
the platoon sergeants and officers
acknowledged that this executing prisoners
was a proper way to behave.
Who were the grunts to disagree with it?
We supported it.
So
they've started to execute prisoners,
which is obviously against
the Geneva Convention,
but the way they're looking at it,
they're seeing that the sergeants and the,
and the platoon commanders are like,
okay with it. So the grunts, okay,
I guess that's the way it's going to be.
Hmm.
And we'd mirror goes on to say the first
time I saw something really bad was the
point at which we
stopped taking prisoners.
We'd been there about a month and a half
or maybe two months. There was one guy,
Medina had shoot the prisoners. Instead
of having everyone around and shoot them,
we would walk them down towards the,
they would walk them down towards the
beach or behind some sand dunes and shoot
them a couple of shots and they were done.
As time went by,
things were done, ears
cut off, mutilation.
One prisoner had his arms tied
straight out on a stick. One woman was,
one was a woman and one was a man.
There was no question that
these two were Vietcong.
The woman was working as a nurse and
we found them in a tunnel with all the
medical supplies and we
knew they were the enemy.
Lit cigarettes were put inside the elastic
of the guy's pants and we watched him
dance around because they
were burning his ass.
Okay.
I think it was a bit of making him talk
in a bit of venting our frustrations.
A bit of both.
I don't remember what happened to them,
whether they were turned over or shot.
The more it went on,
the more you didn't trust anyone.
You didn't believe anybody because
you didn't know who was who.
You didn't know who the
enemy was as we went on.
Yeah.
More and more prisoners.
Prisoners would be executed.
I would say it was a regular occurrence.
I did abuse someone, a prisoner,
a Papasan.
I found myself doing the same things
that had been going on all along.
I found myself caught up in it. We
caught his beard off. That was an insult.
A Papasan with a beard is considered as
the wise man had to cut off their beard
was a real sign of disrespect to them.
You found yourself punching them around,
beating them up, trying to get them to
talk. I never did hit anyone with a rifle.
I've taken a knife to them.
I never tortured anyone to death.
I think I probably saw
people tortured to death.
So you hear this guy using this verbiage,
you find yourself punching them around.
It's almost as if it's not, it's not him.
He's detailed. He's like detached. Yup.
Right. We talk about being detached. Well,
he's detached from doing something that
he knows he shouldn't be doing. Yeah.
It seems like he comes back and kind
of checks back in every once in awhile.
It's like, Dang. I kind of woke up
and found myself doing this thing.
Bernhardt and outsider as usual,
watch the downward spiral.
It started with just plain prisoners.
Prisoners you thought were the enemy.
Then you'd go onto prisoners who
weren't the enemy and then the civilians
because there was no difference
between the enemy and civilians.
It came to a point where
a guy could kill anybody
during an interrogation.
In one village,
here we Stanley was standing only 10
feet away while the Cali and another Gi
Herbert Carter interrogated
and old farmer.
Lieutenant Calley asked some questions
and then Carter hit the old man in the
mouth twice with his fist.
Then Carter push the old man into a well,
but the old man spread his legs and arms
and held on and didn't fall into the
well. Then Carter hit the old man
in the stomach with his rifle stock.
The old man fell.
The old man's feet fell into the well,
but he was holding on with his hands.
Carter hit demands fingers trying
to make him fall into the well.
Then lieutenant Calley
shot the man with Zim. 16
for some Gis instance like these showed
that the official attitude to brutality
was permissive.
What resulted was a moral vacuum,
a moratorium on restraint
and self control.
Common decency became optional.
A matter of personal inclination even
who refuse to be drawn in were left,
left Morley,
thrown off balance.
Greg Olson was in the village when Crowley
and Carter through the old man down
the well,
I was in the village.
I remember seeing people
butted in the head with rifles,
but you start losing your sense of what's
normal. You don't give up your morals,
but you become a lot more tolerant.
We believe this behavior
was pretty common place.
I didn't think we were doing anything
different from any other unit.
You really do lose your
sense not of right and wrong,
but your degree of white right and wrong
and Michael Bernhardt who watched what
was happening from the sidelines was
already viewed with some mistrust by
Medina Kelly and others in the company.
When I saw American soldiers committing
acts that could be called atrocities if
someone else had done them.
I began to think that maybe I
just been too naive all my life,
that this is the way things really were.
Little by little,
I began to see that this group of
men was getting out of control.
Discipline was beginning to wear
off without military discipline.
They were alone in the country
with no point of reference.
The things they had brought from their
families and schools were far away and
beginning to disappear.
Fred,
Weird Mirror felt Fred Woodmere to felt
things going from bad to worse and felt
himself drawn along with the tide.
If it ever occurred to me that things
were getting out of hand or that I was
questioning what I myself might be
capable of doing, I suppressed it.
It did creep up in my mind because you
still have those values of what is right
and what is wrong that you
have been taught all your life.
I think the frustration got to me,
but I also think I began to enjoy it.
That's what's scary because at the
time you find yourself enjoying it.
I guess you could term it this
superiority we had over them.
It's a strange feeling.
In retrospect.
You look back on it and wonder how you
yourself could have done it 20 years
later. When you look back at things
that happened, things that transpired,
things you did. You say,
why? Why did I do that?
That is not me.
Something happened to me.
You reach a point over there where you
snap. That's the easiest way to put it.
You finally snap.
Somebody flicks a switch and you
are completely different person.
There's a culture of violence,
of brutality with people all
around you doing the same thing.
Continuing down the spiral.
Leonard to Gonzales,
a member of second platoon
SAR rapes committed.
Every time the company
went through a village,
okay,
one
squad got one girl, one
lady. Then they told me, go
in there and I said,
no I won't.
So what I did is I went inside
and she looked real bad.
The only thing I can do for the lady is
like, I got the canteen and I wiped her.
She was awful for spiring. I wiped
her forehead. I tried to help her.
She got scared of me.
I was part of them.
I tried to tell her I don't have nothing
to do with it. I helped her to her feet.
I took her to the, well, I
got some water from the well.
Then another squad heard about 13 guys
who did their thing with this woman and
we're going to try her out.
And I told them to leave her alone.
And then at that time I just
walked off. I said, forget it.
I don't want to kill my own men. I
tried to tell her, get out of here.
Go.
She was going to run.
But after 13 guys got to her,
it's hard to walk.
They're losing it.
There's no leadership.
Now the get into a,
they get,
they get in a minefield and they take
some casualties into mind field and here's
Medina's account of what
happened in this mine field.
We started sweeping the area as
best we could with mine detectors,
taking pieces of toilet paper and
marking the minds that we found.
We had one individual that we
could not evacuate that was dead.
I took the medic that was with me,
the platoon medic from first platoon
and he and I moved to the minefield to
where an individual was lying.
He was split as if somebody had taken a
cleaver and write up from his crotch all
the way up to his chest cavity.
I had never seen anything like it.
That looks so unreal in my entire
life. The intestines, the liver,
and the stomach and the blood
just looked like plastic.
We took a Poncho and we spread it out
and started and the and the medic started
to pick them up by the legs.
I reached underneath his arms to place
him under the Poncho and we set them on
top of another mine.
The concussion blew me back.
I fell backward. As I got up the martyr,
the medic was starting to go to pieces.
I looked at him as if he had stood behind
the screen and somebody had taken a
paintbrush with red paint and
splattered it through the screen.
He had blood all over him.
I grabbed him as he started to pass
me and I shook him and I said, my God,
don't go to pieces on me.
You're the only medic I've got.
I have these people that are
hurt. I hit him. I slapped him.
I knocked him to the ground and I helped
him to get back up and I saw on his
religious metal a piece of liver
and I tried to get it off the individual
before he seen it.
The individual was very shook up.
Yeah.
Everybody was shaking.
The three men were dead.
Another 12 suffered ghastly injuries.
Few could forget their own fear or the
screams of the wounded or the gruesome
task of loading the medivac helicopters.
When you've been through a minefield and
put the remains of your friends in body
bags,
nothing shocks you anymore.
So that mind field
costs some three dead and
12 severely wounded in,
we talk about [inaudible] a lot in here.
We talked about them with Jodi,
Jodi medic who got blown up by an IED.
There's no, there's no one to
fight. The bomb goes off in.
That's it. Well, who did
this? Who Do you blame?
Well, let me answer that question
for these guys. Most of all,
they blame the Vietnamese, not the Viet
Cong who they could not see or find,
but the Vietnamese and the villages who
did not warn them of the minefields and
of the booby traps,
same thing my school teacher told me
they're starting to apply the blame to
these,
to these Vietnamese villagers.
Hmm.
Lieutenant Calley noticed the
change in the mood of the men.
He had been on leave at
the time of the incident,
so he wasn't around when this happened.
Hmm.
He'd been on leave at
the time of the incident.
It had returned the Lz uptight
in time to meet the helicopters,
fairing the dead and injured from now on.
The men in his platoon no longer gave
candy to the Vietnamese children.
They came across while on
patrol in the villages.
Instead Cali noticed with some
satisfaction they kicked everybody aside.
Even the nice sweet kids, he could
hardly be refrained from telling them,
well I told you so
now they are starting to,
after that incident they're starting
to now assemble information and
intelligence for this raid that
they're planning in Milano.
So,
and I think it's really important to
take a look to where this intelligence is
coming from and how this cause it paints
a very important part of the picture of
what these guys are being told back to
the book and intelligence roundup for
March,
1968 prepared respectively summed
up the state of knowledge was this,
although some 10 district remained
relatively quiet during this period,
elements of the 48th and
existing local force units,
probably roned roamed
the district countryside,
the hills north and northwest of me
lie area where probable base camps for
elements of the 48th battalion and it
probably received supplies from the
peninsula.
So
the 48th is an enemy unit,
an enemy, a battalion,
and you, you can hear the word probable
being used, gave the probably in the area,
the villagers probably support them.
So there isn't a claim being made from
higher from above the chain of command,
but you're going to hear that change.
So above the chain of command, there's,
there's higher intelligence sets making
these claims that there's probable VC
there that they're probably work in
this area that they're probably getting
supported from the village
as well as this filters down,
it turns from probable to like definite.
There is a strange discrepancy between
what the army thought it knew about the
Vietcong and what the
task force thought it.
New Army intelligence made only tentative
claims by contrast Rams Dell and for
that matter Qutech
we're almost pontifical.
So these are the two intelligence
guys at the task force level.
So does that make sense?
So you've got the higher army above them
is telling them, hey, there's probably,
there's probably that and these guys are,
are basically starting to say, no, no,
this is VC. This is what the what.
This is what's happening factually.
Is that Kinda like, like the game of
telephone? One of the little, yeah, it is.
And it's also,
you're gonna find as I go into this at
both these guys aren't experienced. Mm.
So I'll get to it.
There was a kind of perverse destiny that
brought the two overweight and middle
aged American captains,
Ramsdale and Ku talk together
in Tet Kwong NY city.
Both were new boys to the real world of
intelligence assessment in a battle zone.
Both were inexperienced,
both desperately eager to establish
a reputation Ramsdale had provided to
intelligence,
to Cu tag prior to me lie operation and
the curious convergence of their views.
Irresistibly suggests that it was indeed
Rams Dell who had provided intelligence
for the attack on me,
lie itself,
suggestions at the 48th
local force battalion was up
to 400 strong that everyone
in the village was Viet Cong or Viet
cong sympathizer and that at seven on
Saturday morning,
all bonafide civilians would have
left the village for the market.
All these views were shared by Remes
and Qutech and accepted uncritically by
task force barker.
So think about that.
You got these guys saying there's 400
up to 400 enemy in the area that the
village is all Vietcong sympathizers
and that on a Saturday,
every one that's her actual civilian,
we'll have left at seven o'clock
in the morning for the market.
You can't make that claim about any
group of civilians in the world that
everyone's going to do something
at the same time. Yeah.
Impossible that you could do.
You could make that claim.
Hmm.
Back to the book asked later about
intelligence indicating that no civilians
will be left in the village
at the time of the attack.
Ramsdale replied that the civilians went
to market early in the morning because
of the heat.
Okay.
They testified it appears in a similar
vein in the civilian market and it's
really in population area.
There were several markets,
large markets where all the people would
gather each day because they had no
refrigeration or anything like it.
With hindsight, it appears
naive, even simple minded.
Yet in 1968 this nugget of anthropological
insight along with the corollary that
everyone who is not at
the market was Vietcong,
was deemed unchallengeable
right by Ramsdale,
considered impeccable by Qutech and
passed on on the amended to the bitter man
of Charlie company seeking
revenge for their losses. The,
this is just a, this is a horrible,
it's a horrible situation. And I had,
I had situations like that
occur with me where it was Earl,
my first deployment to Iraq
where we got almost like a movie.
We would get maps of,
of a city area and there'd be a
red x on the target building. Yeah,
you're bad guys in this building.
And I remember one time we went out,
we hit the building with a red x on it
and we didn't find anything or it was all
we all,
we all are the people that we got out
of there turned out to be not the person
we were looking for.
And as we did further analysis,
we realized that the building
was the wrong building in,
in after that I got very
critical about, okay, who,
who put the red x on this building?
Tell me who did that and why they did it.
I want to know, I'm not just going
off of you. Put a red x on a building,
doesn't mean anything to me.
I want to know who did that.
And I had another situation where
we went in and hit a building,
you know where there were suspected bad
guy. We had intelligence on the sky,
was a finance a year and had money
and was giving it to the insurgence.
And so we went and captured him and
searched his house and you know,
Birla blew his door off. So we, we,
we caused impact to his house.
And then when we got him back,
we, after we talked to him,
we figured out this guy was not bad.
And as I pulled the string on what,
where this intelligence came from,
that eventually led somebody to put a
red x on his house and describe the guy
and who he was.
I found out that it was actually he,
the guy owned a business and he had fired
one of his employees and when he fired
one of his employees, well his employee
went and told the Americans, hey,
this guy's a bad guy.
This guy's funding.
You know,
in search it's got a little disgruntled.
So all you had to do is dig in and find
a little bit more about the information
and you figured out it was
a disgruntled employee.
So guys out there in the field right now,
when you're always
questioning your intelligence,
nothing against the intelligence folks,
they're going to do the best they can,
but they're not the ones that are
going to get the blood on their hands.
So question the intelligence,
find out what the sources are,
find out where the information came from.
Ask who drew that red x.
Ask who said there's not going
to be any villagers in the,
in the no civilians in the village
after seven o'clock in the morning.
Ask those questions.
Meanwhile, the loss is these guys
are continued to take casualties.
So they took, what was it,
three killed and 12 wounded.
And now they got Sergeant
Cox killed by a booby trap.
They got a Dyson lost both legs,
Hendrickson's blinded,
suffered groin injuries
and lost an arm and a leg.
So they're continuing to take casualties
and on top of the casualties that
they're taking, you starting to
get an escalation of behavior,
of negative behavior.
And here's an example of that.
Back to the book of village or passing
on a bicycle was beaten up but managed to
escape. A woman working in the fields was
shot when somebody shouted that she was
carrying a weapon.
When the squad came closer,
they discovered she was
on armed and still alive.
They shot her again and kicked her body
to a pulp. Somebody stole her ring.
They were now close to their base and
angry villagers storm the camp and protest
against the murder.
Medina managed to hush it up.
No one was charged with any offense.
Medina said later that the woman had
been discovered with a detonator still in
her hand.
Kelly commented that Medina wasn't about
to lose men just because they kicked a
Vietnamese kid or kill
the damn innocent woman.
He had to keep a combat effective unit,
so now you've got clear cover up
going on by the chain of command. Hey,
she had a detonator,
she didn't have a detonator
and it's very visible to see this downward
spiral from a letter from Greg Olson,
who like I said,
he was the the Faithful Mormon kid and
he writes a letter to his dad back in the
states. Dear Dad, how's everything
with you? I'm still here on the bridge.
We leave Saturday.
One of our platoons went out on a
routine patrol today and came across 155
millimeter artillery round. That
was booby trap. It killed one man,
blew the legs off to others and injured
two more and it all turned out a bad
day. Made even worse on
their way back to to Dottie,
which is there the name of their camp.
They saw a woman working in the fields.
They shot and wounded her.
Then they kicked her to death and empty
their magazines in her head. They,
every little kid they came across. Why
in God's name does this have to happen?
These are all seemingly normal guys.
Some more friends of mine for a while
they were wild like animals.
It was murder and I'm ashamed of myself
for not trying to do anything about it.
This isn't the first time, dad.
I've seen it many times before.
I don't know why I'm telling you this.
I guess I just want to
get it all off my chest.
My faith and fellow man
is all shot to hell.
I just want my time to pass
and I just want to come home.
I really believe as you do dad,
there's a cause behind all this and
if it is God's will for me to go,
I would rather do it here than
home on a freeway. Saturday,
we're going to be dropped
by air in an Nva stronghold.
I'm hoping I'll be able to get out of
here for a few days to go to a conference.
Don't expect any letters from me for
awhile, but please keep writing them.
I love and miss you and mom so much.
Your son Greg.
So again highlighted in there
the normalicy of the guys
and how they're starting
to slide the clear.
It's obvious to,
to Greg Olson that what's happening
is wrong. It unfortunately,
he's not stepping up and saying anything.
He's not bringing it to the attention
of anyone. He's letting it happen.
Back to the book with
these most recent losses,
Charlie company was down to 105 men
since arriving in Vietnam three months
before they had suffered 28 casualties,
including five killed,
three of them in action.
All the casualties, all the
casualties come from mines,
booby traps and snipers.
They had never seen or encountered
the enemy in any strength.
There had been no heavy contact.
They were battle scarred
without being battle hardened.
So you, you can imagine
again, it's what my,
what's what my high school teacher
told me they're, they're viewing.
They're taking these casualty to head.
It's very similar to Iraq and Afghanistan
where I think in in Iraq it was 75% of
the casualties are from ids,
so there's no one to shoot
at after an IED blows up,
oftentimes there's nothing to shoot at.
Now
with those casualties,
with that viewpoint, they're starting
to prepare. As I said for this,
this assault on me lie
in back to the book,
although no written record of the briefing
survives a witnesses all agree on the
general thrust of cu tax contribution.
This is the intelligence officer.
The 48th LF battalion was
dispersed throughout the area,
but the latest intelligence,
the assemble officers were told,
suggested that VC headquarters and two
companies totaling over 200 fighting men.
We're located in me live for the
civilian population population.
We're all active sympathizers with the VC.
By seven in the morning,
most noncombatants would have
left the village for the market.
So just to make that clear
what we're expecting,
they're expecting to go in to me lie
and find over 200 fighting men and all
active sympathizers with the VC.
Now they start to ask some
questions like, okay, what at the,
at the task force level,
back to the book,
what was to happen to the village itself?
Task Force officers left the meeting
with the clear impression that Barker had
ordered the destruction of all houses,
dwellings,
and livestock in the meal
in the Milwaukee area.
Although there is some doubt as to whether
this was a direct order or something
that had been assumed.
Qutech recalled barker saying that
the village was to be destroyed.
He wanted the area cleaned out,
he wanted it neutralized and he
wanted the buildings knocked down.
He wanted the hooches burned,
he wanted the tunnels field and he
wanted the livestock and chickens runoff
killed or destroyed.
He wanted to neutralize
the area for Medina. Also.
Those were Barker's clear instructions
and what was to happen to the civilians.
There is nothing to suggest that
barker explicitly ordered the murder of
ordinary people have me lie,
but the previous failures of the task
force and the demand for more aggression,
the intelligence picture of an community
entirely controlled by the Vietcong,
the bland assumption that civilians
would be gone to the market,
the totally unjustified
belief that innocent people
had been worn to get out of
the area.
In other words,
the entire scorched earth concept of the
operation plan to neutralize the area
drove irresistibly to the conclusion
that here was a free fire zone in which
even the people we're to be eliminated.
Now that's,
so that's the company commanders getting
the brief from the battalion commander,
from the task force commander.
That's the impression that they get.
Now we start to get into your Chinese
telephone game because now how does that
get translated down the chain of command
and even with the battalion commander
talking to the company commanders,
there's,
it's not super solid what the
actual orders were. It's not a,
it's not super solid. No one's said,
hey, they said kill women and children.
It's kind of implied. Well, maybe he
said he wanted everyone destroyed.
What does destroyed mean?
So now we get to where Medina is talking
to his troops and his subordinate
leadership.
The company.
Commander Medina grabbed the shovel from
a quarter ton trailer and drew a map of
[inaudible] in the dirt at his feet.
As he described the coming
engagement tomorrow,
he told them was Charlie
company's chance to get even
Medina relayed what he learned at Barker's
briefing earlier in the afternoon,
the Viet Cong,
the 48 Vietcong Battalion were in me
lie with the strength of between 250 and
280 so actually he just
increased that number cause the,
the report that he was given was 200 now
he's saying between two 50 and two 80
this meant that Charlie company would
be out numbered more than two to one but
they were not to worry because helicopter
gunships would be on the American side.
He told them to expect
a hell of a good fight.
He told them that all innocent
civilians would have gone to the market.
He's just amplifying what he was told
but what was going to happen to the
village.
Yeah.
I told them we had permission.
Colonel Barker had received permission
that the village could be destroyed since
it was a VC stronghold to burn down
the houses to kill all the livestock,
to cut any of the crops that might feed
the VC to cave the wells and destroy the
village.
Okay,
and what was going to happen
to the innocent civilians?
Somebody at debriefing asked him,
do we kill women and children?
It was an astounding question that speaks
volumes about the temper of the men,
but the fact that such a question
was indeed asked is not disputed.
Where testimony is divided
is what Medina replied.
My reply to that question was, no,
you do not kill women and children.
You must use common sense. If they have
a weapon and are trying to engage you,
then you can shoot back,
but you must use common sense.
But many of the men got a different
message. This is sergeant Hodges,
right?
Recollection of the briefing.
This was a time for us to get even
a time for us to settle the score,
a time for revenge
when we can get revenge
for our fallen comrades.
The order we were given was to kill
and destroy everything that was in the
village. It was to kill the
pigs, dropped them in the wells,
pollute the water supply kill,
cut down the banana.
Trees burned the village burden,
the hooches. As we went through it,
it was clearly explained that we were,
that there were to be no prisoners.
That order was given.
The order that was given was to
kill everyone in the village.
Someone asked if that meant that women
and children and the order was everyone
in the village because those people
in that village, the women, the kids,
the old men were VC.
They were Viet Cong themselves or
they were sympathetic to the Vietcong.
They were not sympathetic
to the American marcons.
It was quite clear that no one
was to be spared in that village.
So pretty clear what sergeant
Hodges thought. So Medina says, no,
I didn't tell him. I told him you
had to use their common sense.
If they're shooting at you, then you
kill him. Hodges didn't hear that.
And back to the book.
Sergeant Hodges was not alone.
In his interpretation of
Medina's briefing, many senior
NCO has left the meeting,
convinced that the order was to
kill everyone. Staff Sergeant Bacon.
We were to kill all Viet Cong and all
Vietcong sympathizers in the village.
Sergeant West. It was a search and destroy
mission. We were to kill everything.
Staff Sergeant Fagan kill everyone.
Sergeant Cowen to kill everything that
was in the village enlisted men to
glimpse La Martina Gonzales,
Lloyd Parsh Moss later testified
that this is what they heard.
Flint even remembered the
question someone asked,
are we supposed to kill women
and children? And Medina replied,
kill everything that moves.
Harry Stanley said,
Captain Medina told us
that the intelligence that
established that me lie for
was completely enemy controlled.
He described the formations we were to
use following day and told us to carry
extra ammunition. He ordered us
to kill everything in the village.
The men in my squad talked about amongst
ourselves that night because the order
to kill everything in the
village was so unusual.
We all agreed that Captain Medina
meant for us to kill every man, woman,
and child in the village,
but not everyone agreed that Medina had
ordered everyone in the village to be
killed. Greg Olsen, who's
foreboding letter to his father,
had been posted only two days before has
a completely different recollection of
the briefing.
There clearly absolutely wasn't an order
to go in and slaughter everybody in
that village and anybody
that says so is a liar.
Medina said that any villagers were to
be rounded up in airlifted to refugee
camps. That was specifically
addressed in the meeting.
If I thought I was going to get on a
helicopter that morning with clear orders
that I was going to
slaughter every living,
breathing human being in that village,
I'm sure to God it would have been
so appalling and unthinkable. I mean,
I'm not that stupid.
I know they couldn't have forced
me to do something like that.
Others two denied.
There was any explicit order.
It was like Medina's Ben Addiction.
Michael Bernhardt said he didn't
actually say to kill every man,
woman and child in me lie.
He stopped.
Just short of saying that he gave every
other indication that that's what he
expected.
Whatever Medina actually said,
there can be no doubt about the impression
he made to get the most of the men
to hurt pride.
He offered satisfaction
to grieving soldiers.
He offered a chance to strike
back to bitter and resentful men.
He offered an end to the frustration.
Medina let slip,
the dogs of war
me
lie for was thrown in the path
of their vindictiveness and fury.
Charlie company was going to get it wrong.
It's revenge.
The task force would get its body count
this time there would be no mistake.
So that's where,
that's the attitude that these guys
roll into the operation with and it is
not the right attitude Dav going into
the situation because if case you haven't
figured this out yet,
the village that they're going into,
there's no battalion of Viet Cong
fighters, there's no fighters at all.
And here they start their attack.
March 16th,
1968 seven 15 in the morning
out in the fields of farmer,
frantically raised his hands by way
of both greeting and to show he had no
weapon. He was immediately filled
by a burst from a machine gun
along with the gun ships.
Almost everyone in first and second
platoon's was firing their weapons and now
third platoon was joining in the
moment of Vietnamese was spotted.
Volleys of fire were loosed off and
the enemy fell wounded or dying,
who is a parent to Bernhardt as it was
to virtually everyone gathered there on
the ground that they were
receiving no return. Fire it all.
There was no incoming
hold.
Came across a hut which had
been raped with bullets inside.
Burkholder discovered three children,
a woman with a flesh wound in her
side and an old man squatting down,
hardly able to move.
He had been seriously wounded
and both legs from six feet.
Burke called aimed his 45 caliber pistol
and pulled the trigger causing the top
of the man's head to fly off.
It was a site that would forever
be etched in maples memory.
Burke hold claim to have shot
the old man as an act of mercy.
Okay.
Harry Stanley saw that the fleeing
villagers were offering no resistance.
His friend Alan Boys
who lived in New Jersey,
only a couple of miles from maples
came up behind him with a Vietnamese
foreigner aged between 40
and 50 years in custody.
He wore black pajamas and his shirt
hung open so that Stanley could see his
chest. Boys pushed the man forward
to where Stanley standing beside the
trail suddenly and for no reason.
Boy stabbed the man with the bayonet
attached to the end of his rifle.
He fell to the ground grasping for breath.
Boys killed him and then grabbed
another man being detained,
shot him in the neck and threw him into
a well lobbing and him 26 grenade after
him. That's the way you got
to do it. He told Simpson,
Robert Lee, the platoon
medic, joined in the frenzy,
but can find his efforts
to slaughtering animals.
He killed a cow that had been injured.
Lee was from a farming
community and didn't want to
see the bees suffer upfront.
He and the platoon sergeant,
Isaiah Cowan could see women
and children being slain.
They were stunned by what was
happening all around them.
The further they went into the village,
the more bodies they found
to county, and he's another guy, Conti.
The men appear to all psyched up when
they landed. The shooting wants a,
began created almost a chain reaction.
He joined in without killing
anyone inside the village.
His comrades appeared out of control.
Families huddled together for safety and
houses in yards and in bunkers only to
be mown down with automatic weapon fire
or blown apart by fragmentation grenades,
women and children were pushed into
bunkers and grenades thrown after them.
At one point,
wandering off on his own,
conti found a woman aged about
20 with a four year old child.
He forced her to perform oral sex on him
while he held a gun at the child's head,
threatening to kill it.
Half a dozen people from both
platoons then witnessed a stocky,
blond haired second platoon soldier
from Kansas City called Gary Ross.
Lovitz become a sterically when troops
from first platoon were walking,
a small group of villagers
back for screening.
Raw chevettes age 25 was older than most
of the grunts in the company standing
almost six feet tall and
weighed close to 230 pounds.
He made a surprise grab for Roy Woods
[inaudible] and demanded the weapon as a
trade for his m 79 but
would wasn't having any.
Don't turn them over to the company.
Rush of it's appealed to.
Those gathered there,
kill them.
Wood is physically by far is the smaller
of the two men held tightly onto his
rifle. Roster of Zen, snatched
a hold of Bernado Simpsons.
M 16 turned and shot a Vietnamese farmer
in the head would began feeling sick at
the side of the man's brain spilling
on the ground as he turned away.
Rush of it's shot.
Two more peasants in the head before
handing the gun back to Simpson
in the northern position of the village.
Second platoon had also run Bismarck
employing the routine combat assault
technique used by Kelly Steven Brooks.
Men also approached line abreast in
three squats firing as they moved,
they came to dwellings and yelled out,
lie day in Vietnamese for come here.
The villagers at the villagers sheltering,
sheltering inside homemade
shelters or bunkers,
fragmentation grenades were tossed inside.
Homes were sprayed with automatic fire.
Children aged six or seven came toward
them with their hands out stretch saying
chop chop.
They asked for Food and candy they had
received from other American soldiers on
the two previous visits to the village,
the soldiers Skype them down after one
group of Vietnamese were killed in front
of a hot. The first squad
leader, Sergeant Kenneth,
she'll began telling his men that
he didn't like what they were doing,
but that they had to obey orders.
The villagers at huddled
together for safety,
but the Americans poured fire into them,
tearing their bodies apart.
One man firing a machine gun at random
other using m sixteens on automatic.
Brooke's Radio Operator,
Dean fields,
witness for Natto Simpson shoot a woman
with a baby from a distance of about 25
meters or arm was shot almost
completely off at the wrist.
All that it held. All that held it
on was a fragile piece of flesh.
She ran into a coach and someone yelled,
in order for her and
the baby to be killed.
Max Hudson, the weapons
squad leader formed a machine
gun team with Floyd, right.
As soon as they past the tree line,
they were confronted less than 30 feet
away by a middle aged woman climbing out
of a tunnel, using both
hands. She was on armed,
but they opened fire and she
fell back into the tunnel.
Hudson and right took
turns on the machine gun.
Whenever they came across any Vietnamese,
they opened fire killing them.
Hudson could see people
firing all around him.
The whole scene was one of chaos and
confusion with people moving, yelling,
and shouting. Some of the
troops were afraid they would
be shot by their own men.
Okay.
In the clearing in a
clearing near a small coach,
a group of 15 Vietnamese had been gathered
for women in their thirties three in
their 50s three girls in their late teens
and five children ages between three
and 14 standing around where seven or
eight soldiers from different squads,
including Hutto,
Torres and raw chevettes Gonzales heard
someone yell that if anyone was behind
the Vietnamese to take cover because
they were going to open fire.
A shot rang out when a bullet penetrated
the head of a young child being carried
by its mother,
blowing out the back of its skull.
Others began firing until
the entire group was dead.
Gonzalez could stand no more.
He turned away and vomited.
Few words were spoken until someone said,
let's move out.
Yeah.
A soldier over a tunnel
yelled for the occupants to come out.
Gonzales moved closer and could hear
people responding as if they were about to
comply.
Where upon the soldier through in a
grenade and yelled fire in the hole,
telling everyone to stand clear.
Kelly had been called twice that morning
on the radio by an anxious Medina.
What is happening over there?
Medina did demanded to know challenging
the slow progress of the first platoon.
He wanted Kelly to get his men
back online and keep moving.
This made the young platoon commander
nervous throughout his time with the
company.
He had frequently been made the bud of
Medina's jokes Medina new Cali couldn't
command the respect of his men.
Now under pressure,
Cali replied that large
groups of civilians had
gathered and were slowing the
platoon down.
Never want to accept excuses.
Medina told Kelly simply
to get rid of them.
So when Kelly came across meet low and
conti and the clearing and said take care
of them. His intention was clear. It was
his way of getting Medina office back.
Conti thought nothing of the implications
of Kelly's request when you re simply
replied. Okay. Like many in the company,
he regarded the man as a joke and resented
cat the way Kelly tried to suck up to
the men one minute by calling them by
their first names and then shouted and
bawled at them.
The next conti felt his platoon commander
had absolutely no leadership ability.
Among the squatting.
Vietnamese were 10 to 15 men with beards
and 10 woman women as well as a handful
of very elderly,
gray haired women who could hardly walk.
The rest were children of all ages,
from babies up to early teens.
Calley who is carrying a bandolier
of ammunition on one shoulder said,
I thought I told you to take care of them.
Me Though responded somewhat naively,
we are.
We're watching over them.
No re re posted Cali.
I want them killed. He moved over to
where conti was standing beside me low.
We'll get online and fire into them.
Conti and meet though.
Look to each other and backed off.
Neither of them wanting a part
in what was about to happen.
Cali losing his temper beckoned them
toward him. Come here, come here.
Come on. We'll line them
up. We'll kill them.
Conti searching for an excuse pointed
out that he was carrying a grenade
launcher and he didn't
want to waste ammunition.
Perhaps he could keep guard over by the
tree line in case anyone tried to get
away.
He suggested Kelly turned to meet low
fire.
When I say fire,
Conti stood behind them as Kelly and me.
Low standing side by side, blazed away.
The stood only 10 feet from their
hapless victims. Changing magazines.
From time to time the Vietnamese screamed,
yelled,
and tried to get up.
It was pure carnage.
Has heads were shot off along with limbs.
The flesh of your body
parts were ripped to shreds.
Meet low had taken 23 fully
loaded magazines for his m
16 in his pack when they
had left Dottie,
he fired in a spraying motion.
He noticed one man dressed in red fall
dead as he fired the rifle on automatic
until the magazine was exhausted.
Then he reloaded.
He switched to semiautomatic fire
and loaded the third magazine.
After a minute or so,
meatloaf couldn't continue.
Okay.
Tears flooded down his cheeks,
okay.
He turned, stuck his rifle and caught
these hand and said, you shoot them conti.
Push the weapon back. If they are going
to be killed, I'm not going to do it.
Let him do it. He said,
pointing at Cali. By this time,
Conti could see only a few
children were left standing.
Mothers had thrown themselves on top of
the young ones in the last desperate bid
to protect them from bullets
raining down on them.
The children were trying to stand up.
Kelly open fire again,
killing them one by one.
Conti swore at him.
Finally,
when it appeared to be all over,
Kelly calmly turned and
said, okay, let's go.
Suddenly someone yelled out that more
Vietnamese, five women in six children,
some distance away.
We're making a break for the tree line.
Kelly burst out, get
them, get them, kill them.
Milos face was flushed.
His eyes were still full of tears.
When he arrived with grease sick at the
ditch site and found Kelly sitting down,
we've got another job to do.
He said, looking up them,
about 10 members of the
platoon were guarding.
40 to 50 Vietnamese babies were
crying and crawling around.
James Darcy,
a heavy set Irish Italian from Brooklyn
was looking at a man in white robes with
a goatee beard whom he took
to be a Buddhist monk praying
over an elderly woman.
She was seriously ill and had been
carried through the village on a narrow
wooden platform, which the Vietnamese
used as a bed. Kelly was now on his feet.
Hairy Stanley appeared on the scene and
tried to question the monk who is crying
and bowing as he tried to
make himself understood,
Kelly couldn't understand him.
[inaudible]
who had attended Vietnamese
language classes in Hawaii,
tried more questions and got nowhere.
Kelly was getting more and more impatient.
Where had the Viet Cong gone?
Where were the weapons?
Where were the Nva when
the man shook his head,
Cali struck him in the
mouth with his rifle,
but just then a child aged about two
years and parted from its mother,
managed to crawl up to
the top of the ditch.
Darcy watched horrified as
Kelly picked up the child,
shoved it back down the slope and shot
it before returning to question the monk,
the villagers pleaded
for the holy man's life.
Stanley asked the bearded man the same
questions in Vietnamese that Kelly was
asking in English in an effort
to diffuse the situation,
but the monk vainly replied that there
were no north Vietnamese soldiers in the
village.
There were no weapons.
Yeah.
Stanley translated these replies
immediately. Kalee grabbed the monk,
pulled him round,
hurled him into the patty and open fire
with Milos m 16 as the elderly Mama
Sohn, lying pro streps
prostrate tried to get up.
She too was killed.
More Vietnamese shepherded by soldiers
were arriving on the scene and Kelly
indicated Emilio and boys,
he wanted everyone killed.
He began pushing peasants
into the irrigation channel.
Others joined in using their rifle butts
to shove whaling Vietnamese down the
sleep steep slope.
Some jumped in by themselves.
Others sat down on the
edge moaning and crying,
clearly aware that disaster was imminent.
It was a pitiful sight,
okay?
Until the time all the firing started,
Herbert Carter had been kneeling beside
Darcy quietly playing with a couple of
children. Darcy said, incredulously,
I think Kelly wants them all killed.
Carter said,
oh no, he can send me to jail,
but I'm not going to kill anybody.
Said Darcy beginning to move away and
wondering what would happen to him for
refusing to fire.
Darcy was another one who liked to play
with the children earlier in the day.
He'd been devastated.
After he opened fire and killed
someone running from the village,
it turned out to be a
woman and carrying a baby,
and Darcy was horrified and ashamed
by what he had done. Olsen had seen.
He was really caught up about it.
Yeah.
A woman standing next to Robert Maples
showed him a bullet wound in her left arm.
He felt helpless.
There was nothing he could do for her.
Kelly shoved her in the
ditch and told Maples,
load your machine gun
and shoot these people.
Maple shook his head and replied,
I'm not gonna do that.
Kelly turned his m 16 on Maples
as if to shoot him. Then in there,
maples will surprised and relieved when
some of the other soldiers interpose to
protect him. Kelly backed
off. Seconds later,
he and me low began firing.
A machine gun opened up and one of the
squad leaders tried to usher the man into
line so they can all fire simultaneously.
Darcy stewed completely frozen watching
disbelievingly as the Vietnamese tried
frantically to hide under one another.
Mother's protecting babies.
Yeah.
Screaming at Dorsey above the sounds of
the [inaudible] on full automatic meat.
Low continued pouring
shells into the ditch,
crying hysterically
once more. He stopped for a
second. Why are you firing?
He pleaded with Darcy fire.
Why don't you fire? Okay.
The onlookers saw remnants
of shredded human beings,
hundreds of pieces of flesh and bone
flying up in the air as the shallow ravine
was repeatedly sprayed with bullets
magazine.
After magazine was reloaded
during the mass execution,
it has all this,
okay.
Horrendous scene is unfolding.
There is actually a,
a photographer there,
military photographer,
aim haberly
and he's taking pictures
and he, it was almost like he was
just instinctively shooting. He,
he kind of detached himself.
Hmm.
And here's what he said. I knew it was
something that shouldn't be happening,
but yet I was part of it.
I think I was in a kind of a daze from
seeing all these shootings and not seeing
any return fire yet.
The killing kept going on.
The Americans were rounding up
the people and shooting them,
not taking any prisoners.
It was completely different to my
concept of what war is all about.
I kept taking pictures. That was my
job as a photographer to take pictures,
a normal reaction I have with a camera
just picking up and keep on shooting,
trying to capture what
is happening around me.
I feel sometimes that the camera
did take over during the operation.
I put it up to my, I took a shot,
put it down. Nothing was composed.
Nothing was pre thought, just the
normal reaction of a photographer.
I was part of it.
Everyone who was there was part of it
and that includes the general and the
colonel flying above in their helicopters.
They're all part of it.
Yeah.
We all were.
Okay.
Just a one big group.
Now as all this is is happening,
you've got Medina,
who's the, again, the company commander.
He sorta coming up from the rear
and he starting to assess what he's seeing
back to the book.
While mudita might not have seen
mass executions taking place,
the evidence of his own eyes told
him what everyone else could see,
that some kind of massacre had occurred.
In fact,
it was a worse than a massacre.
Too many of Medina's men were taking
sword pleasure in sadistic behavior.
Several became double veterans,
GI slang for the dubious honor of
raping a woman and then murdering her.
Many women were raped and sodomized,
mutilated,
and had their vaginas ripped
open with knives or bay and nets.
Okay.
One woman was killed when the muzzle
of a rifle barrel was inserted into her
vagina and the trigger was pulled.
Soldiers repeatedly stabbed their victims,
caught off limbs,
sometimes beheaded them.
Some were scalped,
others had their tongues caught
out or their throats slit or both
Tommy Lee Moss saw Vietnamese place
their hands together and bowed.
Agreed Americans only it'd be beaten
with fists and tortured club with rifles
and stabbed in the back with bayonets.
Martin Fagan saw bodies which had been
shot in the head at point blank range.
He could tell because the penetration
of an m 16 round create a shock wave
inside the skull,
forcing the brain completely out.
Okay.
Other victims were mutilated with the
signature c company or the shape of an ace
of spades carved into the chest.
Fagin figured this had been done as a
warning to the superstitious Vietnamese.
It was widely believed that they regarded
the ace of spades as a sign of bad
luck.
Okay.
Troops from all three platoons carried
out wanting and mindless acts of
brutality.
The second platoon were already amongst
the most notorious rapists and Charlie
company. Even the platoon
commander joined in on occasions.
Raw chevettes forced the women too on
dress with the intention of having sex
with all of them. If they didn't strip,
he said he was going to shoot them.
He singled out one woman
telling her to boom, boom him.
She became a Richele and
the other women panicked,
yelling and screaming
and begging for mercy.
Russia vits decided to let them have it.
He fired several rounds
and killed them all
and now we got [inaudible] again.
He's the photographer and
this is what he's witnessing.
Just as soon as I turned away, I
heard firing. I saw people drop.
They started falling on top of each other,
one on top of another.
I just kept walking.
I did not pay attention to who did it.
By that time I knew what the score was.
It was an atrocity.
I felt I wanted to do something to stop
this as though as we were going through
the village,
I asked some soldiers why they more or
less shrugged their soldiers and kept on
with the killing.
Okay.
It was like they were fixed on one thing,
search and destroy,
and that meant killing civilians.
I noticed this one small boy
had been shot in the foot.
Part of the foot was torn off.
He was walking towards a group
of bodies looking for his mother.
Okay.
I put up my camera up to my eye,
I what's going to take a photograph?
I didn't notice a Gi down beside me with
his m 16 rifle pointed at the child.
Yeah.
Then suddenly I heard the crack
and through the view finder,
I saw this child flip over
on top of the pile of bodies.
The Gi just stood up and walked away.
No remorse, nothing. The other
soldiers had a cold reaction.
They were staring off into space
like it was an everyday thing.
They felt they had to
do it and they did it.
That was their job. It was weird.
Just a shrug of the shoulder.
No emotional reaction.
Now,
above this,
you had
above this horror.
You had helicopters that were
flying around. They were,
some of them were gunships,
some of them were there to pick people up,
drop people off.
Some of them were commanding control.
Helicopters were some senior leadership
was flying around trying to observe the,
the battles that took place.
And we do end up with a, uh,
with a, a real hero here, a
hero that's a helicopter pilot
and
his name is Hugh [inaudible] Thompson Jr.
Okay.
And he's flying around
and I'll go to the book.
Thompson marked several wounded people
on the ground with green smoke a signal
that they needed help.
Returning to the mee Lai area about
9:00 AM after the first refueling.
Thompson immediately noticed that people
who were previously injured were now
dead.
There are groups of bodies as well as
many dead water buffalo over the radio.
He warned the gunships to fire only when
they could positively identify enemy
target.
They had good visibility as they
hovered sometimes only four feet,
five feet off the ground.
Gunner Lawrence Colburn in the doorway,
didn't want to look at the corpses
out in the patty.
Fueled beside a dike 200
meters south of the village.
They watched a small group of soldiers
approach and injured Woman Age 20 Thomson
had marked her with smoke.
They were flying close enough for Colburn
to look at her face as she lay half in
and half out of the dike.
She made a feeble gesture with her hand
and was obviously you need of help.
Thompson put the aircraft into a stand,
still hover only a few
feet off the ground.
The high gunship told the
ground forces on the radio.
You have a wounded over
where the bubble is hovering.
Thompson and his crew watched as an
infantry offer officer wearing captain's
bars on his helmet, came up to the
woman product or with his foot,
and then killed her.
Those and the helicopter could
hardly believe what they were seeing.
Minutes later,
over on the eastern side of the village,
they saw dozens of bodies in the air,
negation, ditch movements from the ditch,
convinced them there were people
still alive, not far away.
A group of infantry men
taking a cigarette break,
sat around on the ground and
relaxed taking off their steel pots.
It was obvious there was
no fire fight taking place.
So now what happens is,
is Thompson,
he's starting to get you starting to be
totally disturbed by what he's seen down
there.
So he lands a helicopter and gets out
of the helicopter and he goes over and
talks to a young infantry officer.
Young infantry officer came,
came up,
and Thompson questioned him about
what was happening on the ground.
The officer said there was none of his
business because he was in charge of the
ground troops.
Several members of Cali's platoon
observed Thompson's intervention.
Kelly had gone to speak with
the bubble helicopter pilot.
Stanley overheard Cali telling sledge
forward sledge afterward that the pilot
hadn't liked what he'd,
what was taking place.
He don't like the way I'm running
the show, but I'm the boss here.
Olsen who wanted no part in the executions
at the irrigation ditch had moved to
150 meters out to the patty.
Fueled to set up a perimeter of defense.
He saw the pilot angrily shaking his
arms and just stipulating frustrated.
Thompson lifted off again and
circled the area for a few minutes.
Almost as soon as he took off
his worst fears were confirmed
and [inaudible] reported the sergeant was
now shooting. The people in the ditch.
Thompson began thinking about what
the Nazis had done in the last war,
marching people to a ditch and blowing
them away furious with himself and
everybody else.
He finally snapped.
He flew over the northeast corner of the
village and spotted a group of about 10
civilians, including children running
towards a homemade bomb shelter,
pursuing them or a group
of from second platoon.
Returning to the village
from the murders expedition.
Based on all he had seen in
the village that morning,
it was obvious to Thompson what would
happen when the troops got to the fleeing
civilians.
He landed his aircraft between the
villagers and the soldiers and radioed the
gunships.
He needed help screaming to his crew
that he had to get the people out of the
bunker.
He issued an instruction that bewildered
Colburn if the Americans began shooting
on the villagers. Thompson said
Colburn would turn his machine gun on.
The Americans opened up on him,
blow him away. Thompson urged him.
Colburn turned his gun
around to face the GIS.
Though he was unsure whether he would
be able to open fire on his own.
Men concerned for their own safety.
Collbran wasn't sure it was a good idea
to land in the middle of a combat zone.
The pilot confronted, confronted the
lieutenant in charge, Steven Brooks.
He said he wanted to help get
the peasants out of the bunker.
Brooks told him the only way to
do that was with hand grenades.
Thompson shouted that he would personally
get them out and told the lieutenant
to stay put.
With that,
he went across the bunker and gingerly
coax the civilians to come out.
Crew members in the gunships overhead.
Her Thompson announced over the radio
that an old man was sitting in the path of
the troops near the door
of a small bomb shelter.
Thompson's voice was choking with,
he swore obscenities cursed and pleaded
with the aero crew to come down and help
rescue civilians.
One pilot initially queried at the request
and Thompson threatened that if the
infantry open fire on the civilians,
his machine gunner would turn
his guns on the Americans.
Danny millions are worn
officer on the low.
Gunship realize the delicate nature of
the drama unfolding below and knowing
that Thomson couldn't talk directly
with the ground troops radio,
the hide gun ship to tell the
infantry to stop killing millions.
And Brian Livingston,
the another pilot landed their ships
and flew the Vietnamese two men,
two women and five or six children four
miles away to the safety of the road,
which ran west.
Yeah,
I mean it's uh,
you can't get any more drama than that.
And eventually Thompson gets back
to base and I'll go to the book.
They arrived back at Dottie at about
11:00 AM Thompson got out of the aircraft
and threw his helmet on the ground.
He told his section leader what had
happened and when millions and Livingston
landed, they confirmed it. A group of
them sought out their company commander,
Major Fred Wonky in the aviation sections,
operation van.
They told him everything that he had seen
walk you walked up the hill to the low
ceiling, 10 of attack operation center
and pass the information onto barker.
He in turn quickly got on the
radio to his executive officer,
Major Charles Calhoun,
who was flying in a helicopter over the
battlezone Calhoun was instructed to
find out what was happening
and get it stopped.
There had been allegations
that civilians had been shot.
Barker wanted assurance from Edina that
nothing of this kind was happening.
The order went out to
Charlie company to cease fire
and they did.
And
almost as quickly as it started,
it stopped.
And
it shows you
that this whole time when all
this horror was taking place,
anybody could have stopped it.
Had they stepped up
and said something and spoke.
Now it might've been hard for someone
that's a junior enlisted guy that's 18
years old that thinks he's
carrying out the mission,
but any of those people
in the leadership position
and even some of the folks that weren't
leadership positions, if you're,
if you're there and you start to say, no,
this isn't going to be happening. I mean,
and you did your were some guys
on the ground that resisted,
but no one was able to actually stop it.
It's one of those bizarre things
when I, when I, when I hear that,
that all it took was that order. See
Foreign. Okay, we'll stop shooting it.
Hmm.
It shows you the power of leadership.
Yeah,
and the responsibility
of leadership.
Now as this story goes forward,
the first thing that happens is a big
coverup and they talk about this operation
like it was just a great victory
over the VC and in fact a message.
I'm going to the book here,
a message of congratulations
for the pink feel operation.
That's what the operation is called.
Pinkville was received from
General Westmoreland himself
in a post script.
The brigade commander described the
me lie operation as having been an
outstanding success.
The Praiseworthy Role of units and the
11th Infantry Brigade directly reflects
your expert guidance, leadership, and
devotion to duty. He wrote to Medina,
copying the memo to Barker.
The quick response and professionalism
displayed during this action has enhanced
the brigades image in the
eyes of higher commands.
So there you go.
Within a few hours,
the army's PR machine was pumping out
a colorful image of daring do by the
American troops.
The Mac v Communique issued
later the same day from Saigon,
gave brief details.
The operation announcing that American
division forces had killed 128 enemy,
six miles northeast of quieting city.
US troops surrounded reds kill 128 and
there was another headline that went out
that said,
TF barker crushes enemy's stronghold.
That attitude continues now Barker,
the battalion commander ends up
being killed before he's killed
his. He releases his
assessment of the operation,
and this is where you start to see a seat
cover up written all over this. Here's,
here's barkers official report.
This operation was well planned,
well executed and successful,
friendly casualties were light and the
enemy suffered heavily on this operation.
The civilian population supporting the
VC in the area and numbered approximately
200. This created a problem and population
control and medical care of those
civilians caught in the fire
of opposing forces. However,
the infantry unit on the ground and
helicopters were able to assist civilians
and leaving the area and in caring for
and or evacuating the wounded just lies,
just lies. Then another, another, uh,
piece.
Barker was generally concerned,
genuinely concerned that civilians
be protected in future operations.
And there's no way he could have known
that dreadful atrocity being committed by
Charlie company at the
time it was happening.
But it's clear he quickly
became part of the coverup.
He knew civilians had
died and a lot of them
now the, so, so this starts to
gain a little bit of traction.
People are starting to talk about,
there's rumors.
So even though these big nice headlines
come out and the official report comes
out,
but people start to know about it.
And so they start sending Charlie
company in all kinds of crazy long term
operations out in the field and they
start to feel like, well, go to the book.
Gis felt they were being sent out in,
in the hopes that they
all might be killed.
They tried to bury us
out there with Merck.
Bitterly remembered after me lie.
We went out in the field
for three months straight.
We never came back into the villages.
Our trips to the base camps
were few and far between.
They had a problem and dealt
with us by trying to hide out,
hide us out in the jungle, hoping
we'd all get killed. But we didn't.
So a guy, like I said,
people are talking about it.
There's rumors about it.
And there's a guy named ride an hour
who checks in to Charlie company and he
starts hearing stories. He starts
hearing stories. He starts,
they start telling them,
they start talking.
And this is why you can't
ever cover anything up.
This is why coverups never work.
Never try and cover anything up because
it's going to come. It's gonna come out,
it's going to come out. If
you try and cover something
up, it's going to come out.
That's the way it works.
So
this guy a ride an hour after he
hears enough and he talks to all these
different people that are more involved
and they tell them what they did and
what went down. And he kind of
gathers all that information.
And here we go back to the book
riding Hauer. He writes a letter,
he writes a letter that explains what
he had learned, what he'd found out.
And here we go, right? And Hauer
posted the letter on April 2nd,
1969 to you doll and 30
prominent men in Washington DC,
including President Nixon, the
secretary defense, Melvin Laird,
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
staff, Edward Kennedy, Barry Goldwater,
Eugene McCarthy,
and William Fulbright.
He sent the letters registered mail
thinking that staff opening them would be
bound to take the comments,
the contents more seriously.
And here's a little excerpt from the,
from the letter gentlemen.
It was in late April,
1968 that I first heard of Pinkville
and what allegedly happened there.
I received that first
report with some skepticism,
but in the following months I was to
hear similar stories from such a wide
variety of people that it
became impossible for me to
disbelieve that something
rather dark and bloody did
indeed occur sometime in March,
1968 in a village called Pinkville
in the Republic of Vietnam.
So that's how the story breaks there.
Start to investigate
it within the Pentagon.
They start to investigate it as great.
This book is Great.
It goes into a ton of detail on what
that's like, how that takes place,
the people that are running it and
there's good, honest, solid, you know,
army leadership that says,
oh no, we're going to,
we're going to find out what
happened and we're going to,
we're going to do something about it.
So the cover up isn't
throughout the chain of command.
There's people that that try
and put a stop to it. Now,
the other thing that turns very
interesting on this is obviously
when it hits the public,
and one of the most shocking impacts
to the public took place on television.
And,
and if you remember at this time,
and I don't know if this was like for
for you because you're a little bit
younger than me, but when I was a kid,
we had three TV channels. You know,
there was no 57 or 147 or 1000 TV
channels and there was no internet.
We didn't really,
there wasn't really radio shows anymore.
So if the family was going
to do something at night,
at six o'clock at night or seven
o'clock at night together after dinner,
there was a good chance they were
going to sit down and watch TV.
And now you go back this 1969 so
it's even more focused on television.
And so what happens is this story
breaks on TV with an interview,
and I'll go to the book with me.
Those confession
television was for most
Americans, quintessentially
a medium of entertainment.
Milos confession was truly
an extraordinary departure
from the vapid diet of
soap operas, comedy programs,
and quiz shows. News, however,
was important to American
audiences. Walter Cronkite
was a national institution.
Milos interview was delivered virtually
without warning to an audience of
millions of parents and children
waiting excitedly for news of Apollo 12
astronauts returned from the moon and
the splashed down into the Pacific Ocean.
So that's what that everyone thinks.
That's where they're going to, oh,
let's get the kids to watch the news and
we'll find out about Yay. Yay America,
back to the book. Instead, their
living rooms appeared. The GOC,
his figure of a young man from Indiana,
me low,
brought to the audience are
raw truth about Vietnam.
They would prefer not to have known.
He chillingly described lining up
first the first group of villagers and
shooting them down, expanding four
clips of ammunition in the killing.
There were 17 bullets to a clip,
which Wallace deducted deduced 68 shots
at the ditch execution site.
Me Lo said he was ordered to fire
single shots to conserve ammunition.
Wallace wanted to know why he did it
and here's the interview.
Why did I do it?
Because I felt like I was ordered to do
it and it seemed like that at the time I
felt like I was doing the right
thing because I lost buddies.
I lost a damn good buddy, Bobby
Wilson, and it was on my conscience.
So after I'd done it,
I felt good,
but later on that day
it was getting to me.
Yeah,
you're married,
right?
Children to how old?
The boy is two and a half and the
little girl is a year and a half. Well,
obviously the question comes to mind.
The father of two little kids like that.
How can he shoot babies?
I didn't have the little girl.
I just had the little boy at the time.
How do you shoot babies?
I don't know.
It's just one of them things.
How many people would you
imagine were killed that day?
I would say three 70
what did these civilians,
these, particularly the women and
children, the old man. What did they do?
What did they say to you? Were they
weren't begging or anything? No. No,
or right. They were
begging and saying, no, no,
and their mothers were hugging their
children, but they kept on firing.
Well, we kept on firing. They was
waving their arms and begging.
Did you ever dream about all this
that went on and Pinkville? Yes,
I did and I still dream about it.
What kind of dreams?
I see the women and children
in my sleep some days.
Some nights I can't sleep.
I just lay there thinking about it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
so that's not exactly the,
the friendly news that you're expecting
to see about the Apollo mission.
Now
this thing goes to trial and again,
you got to get into the book to
see how all this breaks down,
but a couple highlights.
Here's lieutenant Calley
during the trial and how he,
how he testified on what he did
and it's a good insight into his mindset.
Here we go. Key lieutenant Calley.
I was ordered to go in there and destroy
the enemy. That was my job that day.
That was my mission. I was given. I did
not sit down and think in terms of men,
women, and children, they
were all classified the same.
And that was the classification that
we dealt with just as enemy soldiers.
I felt then,
and I still do that.
I acted as I was directed and I carried
out the orders that I was given and I do
not feel wrong in doing so.
And
Yeah,
you know, we, we get very used
to the, uh, the media. I mean,
we're in a media circus nowadays
because there's so much media.
There's social media, there's cable media,
there's internet media. I mean, we get,
there's a circus of media
now and you get a lot,
I would say you can get a
lot more distracted. I mean,
new stories here don't last that long,
but this was,
this was a big news story and it was
really dividing the country in a way,
even more so than the country has
already been divided by the Vietnam War.
But in, I'll go to the book
here. To many Americans,
Cali was a hero and they believed
that with the guilty verdict,
he was found guilty. A great injustice
had been perpetrated upon the army.
And in Vietnam they gave an example here
in Vietnam that soldiers at case on had
hastily raised defiance sign that
said a troop first Cav solutes,
William Calley.
So you got people that are saying,
Hey, what, you know, Kelly was,
Kelly did the right thing out there.
On top of that,
uh,
this was a good example of what the
attitude of some Americans were at,
was at a,
a World War II veteran went into an
army recruiting office in Mobile,
Alabama to make an extraordinary request.
He had flown bombing
missions over Germany,
which had killed innocent civilians and
wanted to be arrested for war crimes
despite in,
and another good example
that somebody sent a goat,
a Billy goat of living Billy goat and
send it to the White House and it had a
jacket on and the jacket said,
scape goat on it. And this, this is,
this is pretty cool.
The response that the army
and the government had to
this Kelly is not a scape
goat nor a poor lieutenant singled out
to bear the entire burden of a difficult
war.
Declared a high level army memorandum
circling amongst senior staff at the White
House,
his act stand alone in infamy among known
atrocities for the US forces in a war.
If Kelly is let go or let
off with a slap on the wrist,
the message to all soldiers
must read anything goes.
The implications for the army,
let alone the nation are incalculable,
but clearly in tolerable.
Okay,
so they did a hold the line
and recognize that that
that this was not good.
And at the same time you still got
these people that were saying that,
look, this is, this is a
war and here's, here's a,
a quote from the book
take by way of example,
the following the American soldier in an
officially sanctioned wrath is a thing
so ugly in dangerous that it would
take a Kipling to describe him.
Not a description of me lie,
but the observation of James h blunt,
a young lieutenant later to come later
to become a judge on the behavior of
troops in the Philippines
60 years before Vietnam.
Here's another comment about
what that war was like.
The the war in the Philippines.
Our men have been relentless,
have killed to exterminate men, women
and children, prisoners and captives,
active insurgents and suspected people
from lads have 10 up in idea prevailing
that the Filipino was
little better than a dog.
And another comparison here from the
book in the Dakotas General William
Tecumseh Sherman had written to
General Ulysses Ulysses s grant.
We must act with vindictive,
earn earnestness against the
Su even to the extermination,
men, women and children. Nothing else.
We'll reach the root of the case.
It was talking about the Indian
wars there. And then another one,
just a description that sort of
explains how horrible war is.
And this one was from World War II.
What kind of award to civilian?
Suppose we fought anyways,
we shot prisoners in cold blood,
wiped out hospitals, strafed light
lifeboats, killed or mistreated enemy.
Civilians finished off the enemy wounded,
toss the dying into a hole with the dead
and in the Pacific boiled the flesh off
enemies,
skulls to make table ornaments
for sweethearts or carved
their bones into letter
openers.
Okay.
That was written by an American
warp corresponded, Edward L. Jones.
Okay.
Now
where were those where those ideas
become so disturbing and again,
W war is hell,
war is dark or is evil.
How the things happen.
And again,
when you have a lack of leadership,
things get even worse
and it can happen even to
these apparently normal guys.
And here's Michael Bernhardt talking
about what it was like in what he thought
of people after he got home. I had seen
people who look like everybody else,
normal people doing atrocious things and
I really wasn't sure how anyone would
have acted in the same situation.
I thought I knew human nature.
I thought that people were basically good,
that they couldn't do this.
I thought most of the values
people held were pretty solid.
That when we defined things as good or
bad that they were good or bad and that
we would know when
something was really bad,
but I had seen that this was not the case.
I wasn't sure I could trust anyone.
Again,
I wasn't sure I could ever get close to
anyone or confide in anyone very closely
because of what I'd seen over there.
And going back to the leadership piece,
and this is from the book,
what steps were taken to Holt,
the run of beatings, thefts,
rapes,
tortures and murder,
which prodded Charlie company
down the road to me lie none.
Who among the chain of command that found
on its bottom rung Lieutenant William
Calley and rose through Medina Barker,
Henderson and cost or gave any kind of
moral lead or example that might have
prevented the moral destruction
of the company? No one
in place of clear leadership.
There was paper leadership,
the rules of engagement,
numerous codes of conduct
and all other directives,
all of which contained
the loftiest intentions.
There was nothing wrong with
these regulations and spirit.
They were a recognizable expression
of the American ideal at war.
A blueprint for order
in the midst of hell.
They simply never became
part of the soldiers reality
because they weren't never
seriously in forced and
without emphatic enforcement.
They corresponded as much to the world
of the common grunt as roadmaps of Mars.
That
total lack of leadership,
that lack of moral courage
and
okay,
as we close this out, it goes in
the book here and says, once again,
the darker side of war
has gone underground.
Me Lie is no longer a
public burden or concern.
The burden of guilt and the burden of
responsibility have fallen onto the
soldiers themselves.
Shit,
that man of Charlie company
used to tell each other
rolls down hill
and we'll close out with the words from
Varnado Simpson.
Okay,
who's in his own little private
hell with his memories of this?
As you sit shaking from side to side in
his chair alone in his house in Jackson,
Mississippi,
how can you forgive?
I can't forgive myself for the things,
even though I know that it was
something that I was told to do,
but how can I forget that or forgive?
It's easy for you to say,
well,
go ahead with your life,
but how can you go ahead with your
life when this is holding you back?
I can't put my mind to
anything. Yes, I'm ashamed.
I'm sorry I'm guilty,
but I did it.
You know,
what else can I tell you?
It happened.
It happened
it as we
think about this book
and you should go and get this book and
you should read this book and you should
experience this level of darkness in the
world so that we can all remember to be
vigilant
against this power of darkness,
which,
okay,
I suppose we have to admit
that that darkness is in every man's soul
lurking
and waiting,
waiting for a moment to strike out.
But we,
we need to counter that.
We need to counter that,
that evil
with good.
And we need to do that with
the power of leadership.
And you can see in these situations where
leaders led men to do things that they
knew were wrong.
They knew they were wrong,
things that they didn't want to do.
Killing children as tears are
streaming down their faces.
And if you can lead men to do
things that they know are wrong,
imagine the power and the influence you
have as a leader to lead people to do
things that are right and that people
know are right in that are good
and you are leader.
I am a leader.
No matter what your station in
life or your position or your rank,
you are a leader.
When you step up and lead,
you are a leader and you can make a
difference and you can have an impact and
you can affect the outcomes
of so many things in the world
by stepping up
and leading.
Oh Way from the evil in a way.
From the darkness.
Yeah,
and toward the light.
Okay.
Then I know that was a,
that's a rough book and
this is a rough podcast.
Okay.
In, in, like I said, I was,
I was questioning whether
to actually do this or not.
Okay.
In in at certain points
when I was reading this,
I mean this is my fourth time reading it,
I think,
and even when I was reading it just
now on the podcast for this recording,
I could,
I could hear a numbness in my voice.
I could hear it as I'm talking about the
killing and the gunning down and the f
eight so much,
and I know it's going to be brutal.
I know people are going to be impacted
by this and maybe not everyone's going to
make it through this
and I understand that,
but we owe it to ourselves
to know history and to know and understand
evil and to understand how quickly it
can come about and to see these
indicators and to know that if you're in a
leadership position,
you start to see things going sideways.
You've got to put a stop to them before
they get out of hand before they turn
into this.
Hmm.
Maybe at some point we'll look for
some topics that are a little bit more,
I guess, lighthearted, lighthearted, eh,
but I'll tell you what my only issue
with that is you want a topic that's
lighthearted. You can find them anywhere.
You can go get him anywhere. There's a,
there's a whole,
actually there's a whole section
for a podcast that's called comedy,
right?
It's called comedy that that exists.
There's no section that says the darkness,
I guess there is one.
It's called Jocko podcast.
You want to hear about the darkness,
you want to hear about things that are
going on in the world that aren't good.
This is it here where the people
that are dealing with reality,
okay.
You know, I know this, this is for
everybody and that's okay. That's okay.
You know,
we're talking about heavy topics here in
the reason we're talking about the dark
is because we want to be enlightened.
We want to know about
these things.
I don't think we're going to have time
for Q and a because I just talked about
that book for a really long time.
Um,
so what we'll do is do a Q and
a for the next podcast. And
for this one we'll let
it stand on its own.
And I know it might be a rough podcast
to think about wanting to hear more of
them, but if you do want to hear
more of these podcasts, Echo,
what can these folks do to
support the podcasts? Well,
as I always recommend,
sure, support the podcast,
but you can also support
yourself with supplementation
on it, on it has the best supplements. Uh,
the actual supplements that I take
chocolate takes on it.com/jocko,
you can get 10% off. So support yourself
physically and financially in that way.
Um, I would recommend,
what do you think? Well,
what's the number one you think Krill oil?
I think it depends on who you are. I
thank you for you. [inaudible] Krill oil.
All you, uh, uh, alphabet I like. Yeah,
and they're just a anyway, so
Alpha brain, good for your brain,
makes you think quicker. It makes you
like you did you just say Alpha brain?
Cause I got the whole song right here
for me as Jocko drinks off of brain
instant, by the way. Um, it
makes you think, you know,
like when you search for
words, like in your, you know,
when you're trying to think of a
word sometimes. Yes, yes. From brain.
You feel like Levy pathways to them, the
words a little bit closer. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. Actually you can read all about,
it's called a nootropic Alpha brain. Yes.
Good free rein anyway. A
krill oil goodfree joints.
That's the one Jocko takes.
That's why he's so functional.
I would say for lack of a better term
proving channel. I like that word though.
And warrior bars, that's a new one
right there. The warrior bores that.
That's not like some, you know,
they, they've been having,
well actually nootropics
pretty it needs to,
but you know how you have protein
powder that's been around,
but where are your party?
That's a,
that's a new twist on things that
good about what's good about,
like you talked about protein powder.
That's like a powder, right? Well,
you get a protein bar,
that's a thing that's been
manufactured. Right? Like a bar.
Yeah. The warrior bar is
like food. Yeah. Yeah.
So that makes it a little
bit better in my mind. Yeah.
It's cause I want to eat food. Yeah. So,
so it's kind of like in the direction
of a beef jerky situation, but more,
even more. Anyway, let's look
at it. The thing is there's two,
there's two major differences between
beer for beef jerky and warrior bar and
that is beef jerky, dry
warrior bar, not dry.
Delish. Yup. And then a shroom tech.
Good for like high intensity
kind of prolonged stuff. Do
Jitsu. If you're into it.
Wrestling, metcon met, cross fit.
Well there you go. Shroom tech.
Boom. Yeah, improve your output, your
performance, utilize oxygen better.
Anyway, it's really good.
Like really good. Um,
also another way to support the podcast.
If you're in the mood to,
before you do your Amazon shopping,
go to Jocko podcast.com and click on the
Amazon link. What does that cost you?
That doesn't cost you anything except
for literally literally three seconds.
So your time, three seconds. And you
support the podcast. Yup. I like that.
In one click. Maybe like a one 10th
of a calorie maybe finger clip.
I like that. But yeah, super easy.
The main thing asking people
to donate money there. No.
Amazon's going to donate the
money. Yeah, they're going to,
they're going to support the podcast like
collective. Yeah, it's good. Um, so boom,
there you go there. I guess the
main thing is to remember to do it.
You know when you, you're trying to
get that duct tape real quick. Oh,
I got to make that time so he
can ship that same day. You know?
Then you've got to,
you just want to maybe take some
Alpha brain that'll help you remember.
I like that anyway. Or, or
if you want some chocolate
stuff, like some cool shirts,
Jocko, store.com I'm seeing a new
shirt. Is that correct here? Yes.
We have a new shirt. The trooper
shirt, Dutch. It's got a name.
Are we naming shirts now?
We have to name it.
So this is,
some people don't Echo Charles.
He is an artist.
He's an artist.
And so that's why he has to Dame
the t shirt. Yeah. You know, you,
you just have to name it because that
makes you feel like it's a piece of art
is it's a piece. Because you just said
the trooper shirt as if that's the thing.
But here's the thing though, with this
shirt and with like with all the shirts,
it's not just like, well I'm going
to call it the trooper shirt.
Cause I think that sounds cool.
It's like there's different layers.
It's not just a shirt with a saying
on it. And like this, believe me,
it's not just, you're saying it's not
just called the trooper tee shirt.
It actually is. Yeah. Like we were
coming and you're wearing it right now.
If you're on youtube, you can
check it out. Three colors. Ooh,
that's a unique when usually we'll have
two tellers protest, something like that.
No, but you can protest it. And this
is why. So the people who signed up on,
on the insider's group,
the email list, uh, I,
people that are enlisted troopers,
you know the Jocko podcast there as well.
How do they do that?
Well, we'll jump on Jocko,
star.com right on the front and you just
put your email address and I don't spam,
that's not what it's for.
This is what it's for.
This is one of the things that it was
for and the people who are on the list
notice where,
hey,
I got a new shirt design
idea. You know, uh,
I don't know what colors really to
what are the best colors, right?
I know what colors I like. Yeah,
I'll do a black one. I'll do. But,
so what I did was I sent an email to
everybody instead of what, here's what,
here's the design,
here's what it kind of will look like.
What color shirts are we doing? What color
shirts do you guys like? So there's a,
there was a vote. There was input
received. Yes. Yeah. Like, uh, yeah.
And the consensus was these three
colors, like a dark red. Oh.
Which actually turned out
even better than I thought,
and I was enthusiastic about
the red and the Odi Green.
I support Odie green
that way if you have to,
you never know when you
might have to go tactical
purpose things,
things that can be good for normal
situations or tactical situations.
That's why I like Odie green tee shirts.
Yeah.
Just in case you get a spring into
getting after it spontaneously.
And then of course we've got the black,
but that was the consensus overall.
The green there was a charcoal
had a strong strong, um, you know,
but uh, yeah. Is the green, the red and
the black. But anyway, yeah, it's a cool,
check it out if you want to
look at the details of it
there. Um, yeah, you're good.
Anyway. If you want to support
the podcast that way, get a shirt.
This trooper shirt isn't the only
one, but man, I, I, I'm pretty,
I'm pretty fired up about it.
It looks good. I think. Anyway,
there's other ones on there too that are
cool and a coffee mugs and stickers if
you're down. I like, but yeah, that's
the way, those are the ways and uh,
for the people who have been
and do Dang to say thank you.
It'd be like not even
doing it halfway justice.
Yeah, definitely. Thanks everybody
I feel for doing that. And you know,
you know what's weird,
you always talk about like how you got
to see that you got to see the dark to,
to appreciate it,
appreciate the light. Right.
I actually just,
cause we just got done with that dark,
dark darkness of a book in just
having a conversation right now.
I'm so happy just to be like
here and talking and we're,
we're selling some cool t shirts and
drinking just to be just in this situation
and know that we have this goodness
around us is, uh, is really good.
So I think it is worth venturing into
the dark so that you can appreciate the
light.
If you want to hear more
of this kind of things.
Obviously you've got the podcast,
you can also pick up a book written
by myself and my brother Leif Babin.
It's called extreme ownership.
You can buy the book or
you can buy the audio book,
which is actually Lafe and I reading it.
So you'll get some more
information in there.
And that's everything I talk about
is, is in that book. I mean that's,
that's the basic principles of combat
leadership that we put in there.
Let me add one thing about extreme
that book extreme ownership.
It's good. It's like Dang, this is you fee
or I dunno, everyone's different but me,
I felt like more of an adult after
like 10 incorporating these like,
but here's the thing that you do take
away is the people around you will notice
that you're a better person to be around.
And I,
I thought I was like pretty nice anyway,
but you'll feel people like gravitating
towards you more because like any
abrasive and everyone has varying
levels of abrasiveness in them.
Even if it's just a teeny tiny little bit,
everyone has self.
But what that does is it makes you work
with people in a way less abrasive way.
So people want to be around
you when things go. Now,
I would say that's, that's a very good
assessment and I'll tell you that I was,
felt it, especially when I was in
the, when I was in the military,
in the seal teams, when,
when I was doing something,
people wanted to come with
me. Yeah. It was all good.
We all wanted to get after it together.
So that's probably an
indicator of the principals
in the book at work in my life.
Yeah. You don't have some people,
um, I mean, I dunno, maybe
us, whatever, where, you know,
you'll have a small little
conflict or a little something,
little friction with somebody's
conflict in Wa maybe at work
or even at home or whatever.
I would say it's pretty rare.
Like I'm not,
like if there was some friction
that came up between me and anyone,
even my friend, my wife or something,
it would stand out so much nowadays.
Like it would come up better person,
you become better person. Yeah. That,
and that's at the end. That's all.
But like I said, it's like if you, if you
follow it, if you, you're like, Dang, I,
you know,
I value this and I'm going to,
you actually incorporate
it as time goes on.
That's how it is. Where if you get
friction or some adversarial situation,
even if it's not yours, you're like,
Dang, I see that from a mile away,
you know, and it sticks
out. So it's not, I mean,
some people it's part of their everyday
thing just for road rage or I don't know
any of the thing, but it's, yeah,
it's good man. It's good like that.
Well thanks.
I appreciate it.
Check it out and you can get it on Amazon
after you click through the website,
you know, uh, closing it up everybody,
if you want to talk to us more beyond
that, you can get us on the inner webs.
Echos, add Echo Charles.
I am at jockowillink.
That's on Twitter.
The Facebooky and even have a little
bit to the Instagram going on.
If you've actually answered most of the,
well,
actually every single thing that
comes on Twitter, I will respond to.
I'm going to see how long
I can keep that up for,
I don't know how long it's gonna last.
It's getting pretty hardcore right now,
but I'm definitely reading everything
that's coming in and we appreciate the
feedback we get from you guys and you guys
bring it a little light to all worlds.
Much appreciated.
And thanks for bringing that light to us.
And most of all,
thanks for going out there
and getting after it.
And so until next time,
this is echoing Jocko
out.